c'était un match de légende l'équipe de
France s'incline en finale de la Coupe
du monde c'était un des plus beaux
matchs de l'histoire du football ah non
pas douter et Lionel Messi mérite
évidemment de devenir champion du monde
il est ce soir bonsoir les amis on est
un peu triste évidemment on va voir le
temps de débriefer tout ça c'est un
cahier du service des sports évidemment
c'est Nicole ménardes foot oui je sais
je sais que vous avez les larmes aux
yeux c'est normal on a vibré et c'est le
foot en barako merci d'être ici acteur
en chef adjoint du figaro.fr et puis
salut Vincent roseron qui est déjà avec
nous il est sur place Vincent est-ce que
vous m'entendez votre première réaction
ça s'est passé à Vincent oui première
réaction extraordinaire
oui c'est un match extraordinaire
forcément je vous avoue que surtout à la
k75e on se dit que le match est plié que
les Bleus n'ont pas glissants ce match
que c'est terrible que voilà finalement
ils sont passés complètement à côté de
leur finale et là en deux minutes
touchant on s'est crois on se croirait
on voit les Français qui reviennent et
du coup on y croit mais en même temps
voilà les Argentins méritent
complètement cette victoire la France
mérite de la perdre sur ce qui s'est
passé avant si on a vécu un match
complètement irrationnel voilà c'était
complètement fou complètement
irrationnel mais voilà c'est c'est tombé
du côté de l'Argentin on savait qu'il
était meilleur sur penalty qu'il fallait
éviter les penalty et on a perdu
évidemment trois buts partout on va
refaire le fil de ce match c'est vrai
qu'il y a 75 minutes complètement oublié
mais on les a déjà oublié dans le fond
franchement c'est 75 minutes parce
qu'après il y a un monsieur qui
s'appelle Kylian Mbappe qui a été
gigantesque évidemment grandiose qui
vient de baper bon
Cédric vous avez la main votre première
réaction après un match comme celui-ci
et vous n'hésitez pas on est sur le
Figaro.fr on est sur Youtube vous
réagissez je lis vos réactions c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident d'avoir un
avis un peu rationnel d'analyser tout ça
parce que ça a été comme vous l'avez dit
pendant 75 minutes c'était l'Argentine
qui méritait largement l'équipe de
France en début de seconde période ça
réagit un peu mais on trouvait pas de
solution et puis donc après ce premier
but de Kylian Mbappé sur penalty le
match a basculé dans quelque chose de
fou d'incroyable on égalise en une
minute et puis il y a eu des occasions
de part et d'autre la prolongation est
juste dingue ça se termine avec 40
dernières secondes une occasion
gigantesque de Colomiers
juste derrière non c'était un match
c'était un match de légende ça a été une
finale incroyable pleine d'émotions
bravo bravo Lionel Messi bravo qui vient
de Mbappe parce qu'en plus on a eu on
attendait un duel on en a eu vraiment un
distance non non c'est après c'est c'est
triste il faut un perdant
malheureusement Yoda nous dit bon le
champagne on le bois quand même et il
aura un goût pas forcément très agréable
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec Yoda
c'est ça
non c'est la grandeur de la France je
trouve que on a eu du mal à rentrer
effectivement dans ce match et on a subi
au début mais après c'est bu c'est
pénaux des Killian Mbappé ça a
clairement assommé
l'Argentine de Messi et après il y a eu
encore cette réaction malheureusement de
l'Argentine et les Français j'ai laissé
vu prendre ses caractères qu'il fallait
vraiment aller avec malice chercher les
Argentins chose qu'on a eu du mal à
faire au début et je pense que la finale
elle a été grandiose je voulais vous que
je vous dis ça
quand on a le football et qu'on vient de
voir un match comme ça c'est
d'anthologie
même si c'est pas
consoler dans 10 ans peut-être mais là
maintenant à 10 minutes après on peut
voir
avec un match complètement raté de
l'équipe de France
mais là
la France est grande c'est un grand pays
de football on perd contre les aventure
de Messi
il y a qu'une chose qui compte à ce
moment-là en finale de Coupe du Monde on
ne s'en souviendra pas du second alors
si peut-être parce que celle-là
d'accord
du monde et ce soir c'est l'Argentine et
c'est Lionel Messi Florent moi je suis
sous le choc parce qu'en fait on aime
tellement oh oh que la redescente est
très très dure finir sur les tirs au but
c'est vrai que on aurait perdu 2-0 on
serait dit bon on a complètement raté
notre match rater tout raté là on
revient on revient une troisième fois
dans la prolongation on a cette dernière
occasion de colomani et on perd au tir
au but on sait que les tir au but c'est
pas notre fort on savait qu'il fallait
éviter les tirs buts et on perd moi je
suis sous le choc vraiment au fait c'est
ça c'est ça la difficulté par la police
gardien comme dit vous matinée c'est
très difficile on était pour vous dire
un peu les backstages annoncé dit il va
y avoir les buts on a fermé les yeux
parce que l'anglais était grand il a été
tous les longs ouais il a été tous les
noms mais la compétition c'était pas
facile les Français et je pense vraiment
que le mois et demi parce qu'on s'y
attendait pas à très bien pris son rôle
c'est assez surprenant c'est même
épatant un joueur comme ça qui qui sont
un peu des nulle part et puis on et qui
nous fait un match comme ça il faut
avoir les nerfs très solide pour les
tirs au but bravo à lui deux finales de
Coupe du Monde qui sont jeux penalty
trois finales de Coupe du Monde qui sont
jeux penaltes deux fois la France c'est
pas clean Timothée delaime et sur le
terrain il est sur les Champs-Élysées
Timothée vous êtes avec des des
supporters est-ce que aussi et bien sont
tristes où ils arrivent à se dire c'est
un grand match difficile de penser comme
ça 10 minutes après le coup de sifflet
final
je vous cache pas qu'on lit clairement
la tristesse sur les visages des des
supporters de l'équipe de France avec
quelques jeunes là qui ont suivi ce
match comment dans quel état on se
trouve après une telle finale après un
tel match on a envie de pleurer c'est ce
qu'on va aller faire une première
mi-temps horrible ils sont réussis à se
rattraper en seconde ils ont ils nous
ont fait rêver jusqu'au bout et les
penaltys finissent comme ça c'est triste
après un parcours pareil mais
on a envie de pleurer Kylian Mbappé a
encore sorti un match absolument
incroyable triplé pour lui ce soir ça
n'a pas suffi ça n'a pas suffi on a le
plus grand joueur du monde en équipe
c'est la seule chose qui peut nous
consoler je pense les gars un regard
aussi sur cette sur cette finale comment
vous avez vécu la ces rebondissements
ce scénario absolument incroyable ce
soir moi je trouve que l'Argentine est
quand même bien favorisé par l'arbitrage
je trouve que il y a beaucoup de de
d'arbitre qui sont quand même beaucoup
avec l'Argentine vraiment
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire là maintenant
vous allez vous allez rentrer rentrer
chez vous malheureusement la fête la
fête est terminée
mais bon après voilà on va aller au Mcdo
et puis c'était sur quoi ça s'est joué
cette défaite ça c'est joué à rien non
rien franchement rien au tir au but en
plus donc c'est c'est une épreuve
difficile pour tout le monde alors voilà
[Musique]
les tirs au but c'est la l'autre et vous
le voyez elle est minacée défaites des
supporters de l'équipe de France
évidemment après après une défaite aussi
cruelle et je vous ai annoncé tout à
l'heure le début de la pluie sur les
Champs-Élysées ça y est il pleut ce soir
donc on est vraiment dans le thème
malheureusement oui finalement on est
loin de 2018 le soleil la chaleur là
c'est une défaite bon on est loin pas si
loin parce que ça s'est joué à rien vous
voyez Cindy comment vous voulez être
heureuse après ça vous me dites il faut
rester positif vous avez vu les
supporters français c'est impossible en
langue dans l'histoire c'est les
derniers matchs quand même des Lionel
Messi et ça reste là à vie c'est c'est
match là vous avez envie d'être le
perdant la victime
nous on est des gagnants mais alors moi
ce qui est il y a beaucoup des lectures
par rapport à ces séances de tilobus si
vous demandez à la grande majorité je
pense des gens ils vont vous dire qu'un
match qui s'est fini antido but c'est
pas très beau c'est pas très juste après
c'est vrai que c'est le football c'est
comme ça mais je pense que les deux les
équipes méritée peut-être pas au début
la France mais l'Argentine aussi est là
il a un peu tremblé des jambes à un
moment
mérité de gagner cette coupe du monde
pour moi c'est les parcours de la France
c'est très selon lable et ça vraiment
l'équipe de France ne nous déçoit jamais
même d'un éléphant il ne nous déçoit pas
ça c'est vrai on retrouve Vincent rose
vous êtes devant le stade de l'usaï qui
restera le et bien le comment on dit le
lieu non l'enceinte l'ensemble d'un des
plus grands matchs de l'histoire de la
Côte d'Ivoire le théâtre dans des plus
grands matchs de l'histoire de la Coupe
du Monde Vincent vous êtes avec un
supporter français comment il a vécu ce
match celui-là
et on va demander comment vous avez vécu
cette finale de Coupe du Monde
au final mais bon avec des étapes
différentes une première mi-temps très
décevante des Français manque de hargne
beaucoup moins agressif que les
Argentins mais j'étais persuadé en
deuxième temps j'ai resté persuadé que
si on arrivait à marquer on pouvait
renverser la situation et c'est ce qui a
failli se faire
y arriver
ce qui aurait dû arriver même puisque on
les tenait on les tenait dans les 10
dernières minutes
il réussissent à il réussissent quand
même à aller au prolongations il
remarque mais là encore j'avais de
l'espoir et puis et puis et puis et puis
on égalise et j'étais sûr qu'on allait
éviter les penalty je voulais les éviter
parce que je le sentais mal on le savait
que c'est vilalty c'était 32 dangereux
pour la France les résultats
on perd jamais au final de coupe du
monde on fait des matchs nuls quand
quand on la gagne pas mais c'est
extrêmement décevant et puis bon un
petit mot même si ça sert à rien de dire
ça mais bon
l'arbitre ne sifflait rien rien sur
toutes ces petites fautes Argentine
alors ça pas fait la différence sur des
bus mais au final ça a pu compter donc
extrêmement déçu et puis
on organisera une autre oui mais on a
quand même vibré ce soir à tout à fait
oui non non mais ça aurait été terrible
de finir sur la note de la première
mi-temps
on a on a réagi on s'est bien battu donc
bah moi je regrette malgré tout je
regrette pas le déplacement je suis venu
que pour la finale
c'est vrai que c'était fini à 2-0 avec
une deuxième mi-temps comme la première
ça aurait été extrêmement décevant mais
au moins ils ont bien réagi donc je les
remercie et puis je leur dis à la
prochaine merci beaucoup en tout cas
on va parler de l'arbitrage parce que je
vois beaucoup de commentaires sur le
chat de YouTube sur celui du figaro.fr
qui critique l'arbitre et on voit
supporter qui lui aussi dans le stade a
trouvé que l'arbitrage était pas
terrible je sais que j'ai des bas en
plateau entre Cindy et Cédric je vous ai
posé la question sur Youtube le plus
grand match de l'histoire de la Coupe du
Monde vous répondez oui non on reste sur
ce sur ce match de légende on peut
refaire le film Florence selon vous
comment
le match a basculé comment les Bleus ont
réussi à redevenir dominateur parce que
les 20 dernières minutes la France est
dominatrice et doit presque gagner ce
match tu es le match il y a eu les
changements d'échange où il a tout
changé avant la première mi-temps avant
Louis avant la mi-temps puis après où il
fait sortir quand même Griezmann il y a
ce penalty indiscutable il y a le but de
m.p et on sait que les Argentins ont
toujours été fragiles dès qu'ils ont
pris un but c'était le cas contre
l'Australie c'était le cas contre les
Pays-Bas et là ils ont perdu
complètement leur foot ils ont commencé
à dégager n'importe comment et on a
repris l'ascendant c'est comme ça qu'on
s'est refait la cerise et on les a on a
marcher dessus on a eu des occasions et
puis bon la dernière de colomanie mais
on a les changements plus le penalty de
Mbappe et quand vous avez un joueur
quand même Mbappé qui vous montre la
voie c'est plus facile ouais évidemment
parler de Mbappé comment on a renversé
le match selon ou parce que là 70
minutes 4 rien de rien de rien premier
tiers cadré une tête à côté
à 69e minute il me semble
premier tirer c'est le penalty de Mbappé
si vous avez raison
Griezmann ce n'est pas qu'il a été
mauvais sur ces matchs du jeudi et pas
ça j'ai dit les quais Griezmann était
vraiment les joueurs peut-être les plus
marqués même plus que les autres joueurs
de l'équipe de France qui était
dangereuses également et qui avait une
stratégie et c'est là toute peut-être
les génies aussi des scalion il faut pas
l'oublier d'avoir fait en sorte que ces
joueurs sans problème vraiment du côté
de Griezmann et à ce moment-là les
changements effectivement de faire
entrer des joueurs qui étaient un petit
peu moins ciblé ça peut aider je pense à
l'équipe de France mais effectivement
comme je l'ai dit au début de l'émission
je pense
qu'elle est fait d'avoir vraiment
mis ses penalty au sergents ça les a
vraiment complètement cassé les mollades
on a vu mais si il était comme
inexistant soudain sur les terrains il
marchait enfin il était comme perdu
après il y a eu à nouveau les réveiller
Argentan parce que on est imprimer en
prolongation etc mais ça a vraiment
assommé les Argentins
on a vu une envie énorme des joueurs qui
sont rentrés comment il est possible
qu'en 2 minutes
match bascule
parce que c'est un match insipide avant
ça on est complètement dominé désolé
il y a pas le même état d'esprit des
Français alors certes c'est encore
balbutiant ils ont du mal à être
dangereux et tout mais dans l'envie et
tout il y a un symbole énorme sur ce
match c'est Colomiers certes il s'est
enflammé par maman certes il en a
peut-être fait un peu trop sur certaines
actions mais il a amené de l'envie il
avait tout le monde car ma binga à la
fin d'entrée extraordinaire il y avait
de l'envie ils ont fait des erreurs
techniquesment et tout tactiquement il
n'a pas révolutionné son équipe des
champs mais il y avait pas le même état
d'esprit il a suffi d'un but pour qu'on
voit les les Argentins plongés à un
moment donné la sortie aussi de Di Maria
oui c'est vrai
qu'il avait que 60
mais effectivement quand vous sortez Di
Maria ça casse aussi l'équipe parce que
en fait alors un truc que j'ai pas aimé
de l'équipe de France et j'ai oublié de
le dire du côté des dîner souvent on les
retrouvait tout il y avait aucun dur
pour venir au fait di Malia avait un
boulevard il y avait aucun joueur de
l'équipe de France pour les pour les
venir les tacles donc je pense que c'est
aussi qu'on a un petit poupée vous savez
j'ai l'impression que c'est 70 premières
minutes elles font pas partie de ce
match oui ce que je veux dire c'est pas
la même chose on a oublié déjà c'est
loin Vincent roseron vous sur place
comment vous avez senti cette bascule ce
match qui devient légendaire alors qu'il
est insipide jusqu'ici
bah c'est complètement irrationnel ce
qui s'est passé enfin vraiment les les
les Argentins nous contrôlaient
complètement et là on marque un penalty
et dans la dans la foulée on voit ce on
voit comment qui récupère cette cette
balle dans les jambes de Messi qui part
on a cette balle qui arrive et quand il
reçoit là-bas on se dit tous bah oui il
va marquer en fait on voit pas comment
il ne peut pas marquer alors que bon euh
je sais pas 95% des des joueurs de la
mettrai pas lui il la met de façon
magnifique et là on se retrouve à deux
et on se dit bah en fait ouais c'était
facile en fait le football il suffisait
d'avoir ce penalty et un but de Mbappé
et après c'est reparti comme ça
l'ambiance dans le stade à ce moment-là
attendez je reste avec Vincent parce que
ça ça m'intéresse nous on doit faire le
coup devant la télé on se met à crier on
écoute même plus les commentaires
comment on devient l'ambiance dans le
stade on entendait beaucoup les
Argentins à ce moment-là est-ce que d'un
seul coup c'est les Français qui
exposent et les argentins qui deviennent
silencieux racontez-nous
alors c'est compliqué de dire que les
Français ont fait plus de bruit que
l'Argentin parce que dans le vin était
tellement surnombre dans ce stade que
c'était très compliqué mais oui on a
entendu des allez les bleus allez les
bleus qui ont dominé pendant deux trois
minutes après le penalty vraiment on a
les Bleus allez les bleus sur le but de
Mbappé je pense que c'est les Bleus qui
doit faire le plus de bruit à ce
moment-là en plus et après voilà les
Argentins s'en remettent à 4 à 85e on
les entend énormément mais pendant un
court moment voilà c'est le c'est le
football c'est un match c'est ça ça joue
sur des moments et là ça devient
irrationnel et en deux minutes Mbappé tu
as joué avec les fionel qui est capable
de marquer débute comme ça il lui faut
pas 46 occasions une et demi ça lui fait
deux buts commentaires plutôt rigolo de
la mayonnaise sur Youtube au tir au but
ils ont fait passer des stagiaires dans
l'équipe de France en même temps et oui
c'est vrai que ça peut jouer au bout
d'un moment cette équipe de France le
manque d'effectif et talent parce que on
le sait au début de la Coupe du Monde il
y a eu beaucoup d'absents
d'un autre côté je trouve comme
exceptionnel et c'est vrai que si une
fois qu'on aura laissé passer la
déception de ce qu'on a vécu là et tout
faudrait quand même bien se dire que il
a sorti Giroud à la 40e il a sorti
Griezmann à la 60e c'est quand même deux
tôliers donc
Varane était quand même sans doute
diminué et tout il a on va on va à 3 3
et tout avec une équipe jeune avec colo
moignies avec Konaté à la fin avec ou
pas mécano disacy Kama vinga il faudrait
j'ai pas j'ai pas assez de temps pour
analyser mais le 11 joueurs qu'on a à la
fin j'aimerais bien voir la moyenne
d'âge qu'on a quoi et puis surtout
l'expérience vous le disiez cette
défense mais il y avait du cœur les
quatre défenseurs des 10 dernières
minutes soit cela et du talent mais il y
a une expérience
bon je pense que pas grand monde ne les
connais en France du grand public et on
espère évidemment qu'il le deviendront
cette statistique
Randal colomani a remporté 13 duels lors
de cette finale au moins quatre de plus
que tout le temps
un peu méconnu je veux dire
allez on continue vous réagissez
évidemment vous voulez pour l'instant le
temps de passage de mon petit sondage
sur Youtube est-ce le plus grand match
de l'histoire de la Coupe du Monde oui à
76 % bien sûr je sais pas trop mais
imaginons
oui oui mais c'est pas une finale de
Coupe du Monde il y a quand même c'est
l'Argentine l'Argentine de Messi c'est
bapé en face qui est grandiose qui se
termine au tir au but avec je vous dis
pas que c'est pas le plus gros mais il y
a il y a quand même l'histoire de la
Coupe du Monde et pavé aussi de quelques
très très grand match presque
irrationnel et tout dans un sens ou dans
un autre moi je garderai mais en mémoire
aussi quand même
l'Allemagne Brésil le 7 1
vous voyez ce que je veux dire oui il y
a pas les mêmes émotions mais cette
espèce de perfection d'une équipe sur un
match c'était mais bon Florent vous avez
une idée d'un plus grand mal dans
l'histoire de la Coupe du Monde au XXIe
siècle non je pense pas non je pense pas
que c'est véritable scénario la folie
des à partir de la 70ème minute on est
au delà je pense qu'on est au delà du
foot on entre dans quelque chose c'est
la magie du sport Cindy et on se
souvient plus de ce match il y a 4 ans
qui était le plus beau match de la Coupe
du monde le France Argentine il y a 4
ans honnêtement et à nouveau ce France
Valentine cette fois en finale est le
plus beau match de cette Coupe du Monde
et peut-être de l'histoire du foot si
vous aimez les football romantique
parce que aussi c'est les passages des
témoins des messies qui du coup fait sa
révélance de la plus belle des manières
et ensuite bapé qui montre que il est là
donc en fait il y aura c'est pas que la
personne la relève est là elle était sur
le terrain c'est soit là et il va être
énorme il a énormément d'années devant
lui et sans oublier également d'images
qui est c'est sûrement également sa
dernière Coupe du monde et qui nous a
montré qu'il est un très grand jeu
pour l'instant pas que beaucoup de
supporters autour de lui c'est normal
puisque on n'a pas encore été remise et
il y en aura bientôt on le sait vous
parlera avec eux et essayer de trouver
argentin aussi qu'on s'amuse un peu
Vincent leur donner le sourire les
Argentins vous Vincent vous rendez
compte que vous avez peut-être vécu l'un
des plus grands matchs de l'histoire du
foot est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres comme
ça dans votre imaginaire qui pourrait
concurrencer celui-là ou pas
alors la fidèle Espagne Pays-Bas en 2010
peut-être non je rigole pas du tout non
non effectivement là on était sur un
match absolument incroyable en fait on
avait vu en quart de finale déjà un
Pays-Bas Argentine qui était fabuleux
avec à peu près le même scénario
l'argentique qui contrôle tout et qui
prend deux buts coups sur coup qui qui
perd complètement les pédales et voilà
et c'est ça bascule aussi complètement
mais non sinon dans dans l'histoire
récente moi je me souviens pas d'un
match ou comme ça où on vibre comme ça
voilà vous l'avez dit il y avait le
frangin argentine de 2018 mais oui là
c'était complètement après ouais sauf
qu'on a vécu 80 minutes où on s'est dit
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fout là quoi
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que la France
est en train de faire on est
complètement en train de passer
complètement complètement à côté de
notre finale et finalement si ça ça
devient un match de légende et on ne
sait pas trop pourquoi Mélanie du Québec
coût dure pour la France mais
l'Argentine a été meilleur par contre
les Bleus n'ont pas lâché bravo aux deux
équipes oui c'est ce qu'on retiendra
évidemment je pense que les joueurs de
l'équipe de France il retiendront pas ça
et retiendront qu'ils ont perdu mais
après on a pas parlé quand vous parlez
des mages c'est vrai que 98 pour en
français une victoire en France ça reste
quand même comme un très grand match
j'imagine pour les Français je suis pas
sûr que dans l'imaginaire dans le monde
entier on retourne sur les
Champs-Élysées avec Timothée delaime
l'un de nos autres envoyés spéciaux il
est en France avec des supporters
forcément tristes Timothée forcément
peut-être pas dites-nous qu'en penses-tu
oui Thibault avec des supporters
français vous me disiez à l'instant on
est triste on est déçu mais quand même
comment vous avez vécu la ce scénario
complètement dingue on était mené de
zéro finalement on revient au score
comment vous avez vécu ce retournement
de situation
vive la France dédicace à la danse
qu'est-ce qu'il a manqué à l'équipe de
France là pour remporter ce match de la
chance de la chance hein la fin c'est
que de la chance que de l'âge il a
manqué que de la chance ouais c'est mal
fini au penalty on aurait pu mérité
on va être beau joueur justement Lionel
Messi qui remporte la Coupe du Monde il
continue d'écrire sa légende toute façon
il est au PSG voilà
vous vous serez là pour le retour des
Bleus à Paris
on leur en veux pas trop c'est ça ce que
vous dites et là là c'est pas la même
chose là bon pas trop de déception en
tout cas on reste on reste positif
allez les bleus allez les bleus on
essaie de on essaie
[Applaudissements]
voilà on essaie de rester fier on essaie
de rester positif ici sur les
Champs-Élysées pour ces supporters de
l'équipe de France évidemment grosse
grosse déception et vous le voyez il y a
quand même du sourire sur les visages et
ça fait du bien de la Ferté c'est ce
qu'on entend et on peut on peut être
fier de cette équipe de France il y a
pas d'autre c'est intéressant ce qu'ils
disent euh qu'est-ce qu'il a manqué de
la chance une séance de tir au but
est-ce que ce n'est que de la chance
parce que on sentait que ça allait être
compliqué par rapport à l'expérience des
tireurs et nous a manqué je le lance
tout de suite ou pas
allez-y
un arbitre compétent
au niveau normalement
on parle de l'arbitrage pourquoi pas
parce que j'ai beaucoup de commentaires
sur YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr sur cette
question et vous n'hésitez pas à vous
continuez à nous demander si l'arbitrage
à nous dire si l'arbitrage a été à la à
la hauteur allez-y allez-y Cédric est-ce
que pour vous l'arbitre a été bon est-ce
qu'il a influé sur le résultat de cette
rencontre alors ce que je vais dire ne
sonne peut-être pas très fig euros mais
l'arbitre a été à chier non vous
refaites mais poliment poliment il n'a
pas été au niveau de cette finale c'est
dommage qu'il ait oublié au moins trois
ou quatre cartons jaunes du côté
argentins et que il était parfois
dépassé le tag de Paredes c'est un
attentat monstrueux sur cama binga qui
est méritait un rouge donc lui il aurait
pas dû tirer de penalty hakunir pour
l'ensemble de son œuvre aurait pas dû
finir le match non plus je reste
persuadé mais j'ai pas revu suffisamment
de ralenti qui a pas de penalty le
premier penalty de l'Argentine n'y est
pas sur Di Maria je pense qu'ils tombent
tout seul donc je trouve que ça fait
quand même beaucoup sur un match je
viens de poser la question je le dis sur
Youtube l'arbitre a-t-il été à la
hauteur de cette fin de la Coupe du
Monde on va voir ce qu'on pense
bah ouais tendance à dire vous savez ce
qu'on va faire je reviens vers vous
Flora et Cindy pour parler de
l'arbitrage Vincent roseron une réaction
avec ce supporter qui est avec vous
devant le stade et vous lui demandez
est-ce que l'arbitre a été bon
je vais demander à cette surface comment
vous avez trouvé l'arbitre ce soir
mais on peut pas être totalement
satisfait quand même d'un arbitrage
comme celui qu'on a vu ce soir pour une
finale de Coupe du monde je pense que il
a quand même plutôt avantagé les
Argentins moi j'aurais aimé qui sifflent
quand même un peu un peu plus un peu
plus souvent et s'il avait sorti
quelques cartons jaunes contre les
Argentins ça aurait peut-être été quand
même un peu plus un peu plus équitable
on va dire au-delà de ça au niveau de ce
match quand même on a quand même vécu un
grand match de football ah ouais c'était
spectaculaire on revient deux fois au
score on espérait tous faire le doubler
malheureusement la situation on a on a
été autrement si on doit sortir un
joueur de ce match c'est Kylian Mbappe
ou si c'est ce sera des entrants
Killian on peut le féliciter pour pour
les buts qu'il a inscrit évidemment
parce que c'est lui qui nous remet dans
la partie à chaque fois mais moi j'ai
trouvé que les rentrées des deux de
Thuram et de
ont été nous ont apporté beaucoup plus
de puissance devant et
ils se sont vraiment battus et ils nous
ont permis de
mieux défendre on a on a commencé à
défendre en avançant donc c'était quand
même plus intéressant et c'est grâce à
ça je pense qu'on a on a pu marquer très
bien merci beaucoup en tout cas et
pendant une autre une autre fois
très bien merci beaucoup
confirmer c'est absolument
extraordinaire j'ai l'impression qu'on
entend les chants des supporters
argentins qui ne s'arrêtent pas derrière
vous c'est bien ça
oui bah alors en fait alors moi
j'entends là-bas alors là ils ont passé
là il passe de la musique dans le stade
actuellement donc j'entends moins les
supporters mais voilà le match est
terminé depuis déjà un bon moment et je
vous dire qu'il y a pas grand monde qui
est sorti alors forcément il y a la
cérémonie mais les Argentins même sans
cérémonie ils ont l'habitude de rester
dans les tribunes pendant encore 45
minutes au moins après le match pour
chanter à la gloire de leur joueur il
peut quotidien un très beau match ouvert
jusqu'au bout et les tirs au but comme
souvent c'est pile ou face mais c'est
comme ça Fabienne beau match d'une
finale de Coupe du monde malgré la
déception bravo l'équipe de France
champion du monde l'Argentine on revient
sur cette question de l'arbitrage parce
qu'on avait ouvert le débat Cédric
allier a joué le rôle du procureur de ce
côté-là je sais que Cindy Colmenares
jouera l'avocat de ce
morceau
avec Cédric non seulement il y a des
fautes qui n'ont pas été sifflées des
cartons jaunes qui ont pas été
distribués le premier penalty en effet
il y a même pas un appel à la barre mais
aussi le
un mauvais sens du jeu c’est-à-dire que
parfois il laisse un avantage qui
revient alors les 10 dernières minutes
du temps réglementaire alors que
l'Argentine est coupé en deux avec la
vitesse et la confiance accumulée par
les Français dans les derniers instants
ce qu'il fait c'est dramatique
complètement contre-temps dans les 30
dernières minutes alors que complètement
un ballon à 80 mètres du but de
l'Argentine alors que vous avez Mbappé
koman et colomanie et Thuram c'est
quasiment l'occasion clairement il y a
une action où il y a une faute sur coman
mais coman arrive à se relever et à
reprendre le ballon et il y avait Mbappé
qui était qui était presque seul il me
semble-t-il il me semble-t-il
la faute et il ne met même pas de carton
sur cette action il met un carton jaune
alors que justement on ne veut pas et le
coup d'avant
moi il a été complètement débarrassé de
revenir ensuite il est pas obligé
d'interrompre une action qui enfin
c'était contre contre l'esprit du jeu
quoi c'est simple donc Adeline nous dit
cédric est vraiment Chauvin et vous avez
raison et vous continu
n'importe qui et au moins cinq ou six
actions
avec Cédric allier ça vaut le coup parce
que là il se tient
alors cet arbitre il a été bon ou pas
vous savez pourquoi on aime les Français
parce qu'ils sont des très mauvaise foi
du tout on adore j'adore je me régale
non en réalité
l'arbitre je trouve qu'il a les mérite
d'avoir tenu une finale qui était quand
même pas facile angle blanche je
considère que il y a très peu de cartons
par rapport à ce qui aurait dû y avoir
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des fautes
effectivement qui n'ont pas été sifflés
je trouve qu'un match quand on voit que
l'Argentine je viens de regarder c'est à
peu près cinq cartons jaunes c'est ça
qui sont pris je me dis c'est quand même
c'est quand même rien par rapport à une
équipe comme l'Argentine qui avait fait
quand même un record contre les Pays-Bas
du nombre des cartons
de quel côté banquet-il des cartons
vous avez sorti Cdiscount là donc je
veux bien que vous les dites sur la fin
du match et effectivement il a été un
petit peu moins en rendez-vous mais là
vous êtes des très mauvaise foi mais on
attend ce soir
vous étiez en train de dire aller contre
l'habitage mais ça c'est très français
et ça c'est le moment changer bon
Vincent vous sur place cet arbitre vous
en avez pensé quoi il vous a marqué ou
non finalement pas tant que ça et c'est
pas pour ça qu'on est pas champion du
monde ce soir ah oui oui
alors je sais pas si c'est pas pour ça
qu'on est champion du monde mais il y a
plusieurs plusieurs éléments le premier
élément et ça on l'a bien vu en fait
quand même alors déjà dans une première
chose c'est que depuis le début de cette
Coupe du Monde il y a clairement des il
y a clairement des consignes de news
arbitres sur les cartons en fait il ne
donne pas de carton il donne pas de
carton jaune vraiment et les Argentins
en profitent depuis le début de la
compétition ils ont raison de le faire
ils ont toujours ils ont raison de jouer
dur quand on voit qu'ils prennent pas de
carton jaune ils ont complètement de
raison de de jouer comme ça mais en fait
ce qui s'est passé lors de ce match ça
s'est passé depuis le début de cette
Coupe du Monde deuxièmement cet arbitre
a quand même largement favorisé ce qui
était ce qui avait la comment dire le
momentum ce qui était dans dans une
bonne phase en début de Paris en début
de partie les Argentins
vont duel bouffent les Français
clairement et du coup
l'arbitre est on va dire assez sympa
avec eux mais il est aussi avec nous cet
arbitre en fin de match quand nous aussi
on commence à mettre un peu de d'impact
quand on rentre dedans et où les
Argentins se plaignent et là aussi ça ça
tombe pour nous je suis entièrement
d'accord en tout cas sur les cartons
c'est vous dire Romero fini le match
sans carton jaune c'est alors que dès le
début du match il nous met un petit coup
de coude sur Hugo Lloris très sympa il
finit avec un carton jaune je sais pas
combien il est de fautes il faudrait
quand même compter 5 ou 6 je pense
pareil par EDF je pense que c'est rouge
à peu près tous les jours mais bon et le
penalty oui s'il peut siffler et c'est
léger mais après sur les 80 premières
minutes je veux dire on l'arbitrage n'a
que très peu d'importance puisque les
Français n'y sont pas du tout se font
complètement manger et voilà moi j'ai
pas envie d'en vouloir à l'arbitre sur
les 80 premières minutes après oui je me
rappelle très bien de cette action aussi
sur cobad qui se fait saturer qu'il veut
repartir et et et ça s'arrête je vous
avoue en tribune de presse ça a beaucoup
beaucoup aller à ce moment-là on n'a pas
vraiment bien compris et voilà et je
pense qu'avec mes collègues on en
parlait aussi je pense qu'on se
souviendra de la performance de cet
arbitre j'aime beaucoup Vincent parce
que il le démonte pendant 10 pendant 30
secondes il s'en va il accélère et puis
surtout ah non bon je leur veux pas cet
arbitre vous présent Vincent vous êtes
diplomate penalty donc si si moi j'ai
pas envie d'être un ton péremptoire
parce que j'ai pas revu suffisamment de
ralenti je veux mais je vais les
regarder s'il y a pas faute sur Di Maria
je suis désolé on peut pas oublier c'est
quand même l'ouverture du score de
l'Argentine donc ça n'enlève je pense
voilà ça n'enlève rien on mérite de
l'Argentine on va pas mais quand même
des choses qui vont sur la faute sur Di
Maria le premier
penaltyle comme ça
je crois que c'est Dembélé qui a été
déstabilisé sur ce sur cette facture
il a un carton pour simulation
plus important et puis voilà il y a ça
et effectivement il y a ce truc de coman
il y a la faute de Paredes et symbolique
pour moi de son arbitrage il y a
ceinturage un moment donné de Messi qui
empêche clairement un compte de
développer et et il met pas de carton
jaune alors c'est Lionel Messi donc il a
le droit de
alors sachez que sur YouTube à la
question l'arbitre a-t-il été à la
hauteur de cette finale de Coupe du
Monde et bien c'est un OUI à 72%. tu
m'attends pas convaincre voilà
nos internautes a été à la hauteur dans
cette finale je vois les mêmes ralenti
que sur le vrai
peut-être pour avoir un score pareil
vous avez mis en espagnol
j'imagine et je sais qu'il y a Mélanie
du Québec par exemple qui me dit on
regarde de partout donc on est
internationaux bon qui vient de Mbappé
était lui meilleur buteur de la Coupe du
Monde il a son trophée en main il fait
la tête lionel Messi est élu meilleur
joueur de la Coupe du Monde on parle de
Messi allez un petit peu même si on est
triste évidemment ce soir il est 19h32
si vous nous rejoignez l'équipe de
France c'est un client final de la coupe
du monde au terme d'un match légendaire
3 3 et puis elle s'est effondrée cette
de France au tir au but après être
revenu dans la rencontre alors que
c'était pourtant bien mal embarqué
Lionel Messi est-il devenu ce soir
Laurent le plus grand joueur de
l'histoire du foot il a toujours moi je
n'aime pas trop comparer les parce que
c'est pas les mêmes époques
si on prend sur le plan purement
palmarès oui il a le plus grand nombre
de ballon d'or il vient de remporter la
la il a tout gagné donc oui forcément
moi ce qui m'a impressionné c'est que
c'est ça coupe du monde c'est à dire que
il a marqué en face de poules il a
marqué en 8e en cas en 2000 en finale il
a porté son équipe on sent que les
joueurs de l'équipe argentine ont voulu
la gagner pour lui donc il a il a marché
sur cette coupe du monde je trouve alors
certes le premier pelty bon on en dira
mais après le deuxième but qu'il met il
est bien opportuniste il prend ses
responsabilités il marque le premier tir
au but c'est ça coupe du monde j'ai posé
la question sur Youtube la même et on
attend de voir la réponse de
de nos internautes j'ai entendu Venise
il a toujours été il y a des bas quand
même vous m'avez pas répondu Florent
vous avez fait une réponse de Normandie
avec des supporters français est-ce
qu'on retrouve un peu le sourire ou
c'est la soupe à la grimace
et ben on va leur demander Thibault
est-ce que vous retrouvez le sourire ou
c'est la soupe à la grimace ce soir
venez quand même
tous les copains
on est deuxième c'est déjà bien donc
le meilleur joueur de l'équipe de France
ce soir c'est qui Mbappe qui met ça
un mot sur Lionel Messi qui remporte la
Coupe du Monde c'est le meilleur joueur
du monde Lionel Messi définitivement ça
reste un bon joueur un très bon joueur
comment vous avez vécu ce match vous
vous étiez dans un bar sur les champs
chez moi quel était l'ambiance là
pendant ce temps
première mi-temps compliquée et puis
c'est vrai que la deuxième mi-temps
était assez fabuleuse on a réussi
vraiment à faire une remontada
j'entendais un supporter qui disait que
c'est le match le plus fou qui n'est
jamais vu est-ce que c'est votre code
oui oui
effectivement je confirme j'ai compris
c'était l'euphorie c'est c'est fou quand
même d'arriver à
égaliser après bah la position de
l'Argentine bon la première mi-temps qui
était quand même comment vous avez agi
réagi là quand Mbappe a marqué ce but
complètement fou en prolongation
on a filmé on a chanté la Marseillaise
on était fier d'être français plus que
jamais voilà on essaie de garder le
sourire ici
ça doit bien se Tibo c'est le principal
et ils sont fiers d'être français nous
aussi après ce qu'on a vu pendant 70
minutes on avait plutôt envie de se
cacher sous cette table et puis après
oui on a un peu bombé le torse grâce à
Kilian Mbappé et incroyable je lis
partout là dans les commentaires
lorsqu'on entend ces jeunes il est en
train d'entrer dans le cœur des Français
c'est incroyable on s'en doutait mais
c'est très beau on parlait Lionel Messi
le plus grand joueur de l'histoire après
cette coupe du monde ce soir c'est une
école ménage oui et puis au fait vous
savez pour les Argentins il y a toujours
le balladona parce que c'est vraiment
l'enfant du pays etc mais la différence
avec Messi c'est qu'elle a dans ces
mondial non seulement il s'est relevé
vraiment en marquant dans chaque partie
de la compétition du tournoi mais
également je trouve que c'est un joueur
qui a toujours été assez exemplaire
contrairement peut-être qu'un malade on
a qui sa carrière et sa vie a peut-être
un peu plus dérapé je trouve que Messi
est un exemple
j'ai pas du tout contrôler
pour les prochaines régénérations
l'Argentine ce soit aussi Messi mais
qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière le plus
grand joueur de l'histoire moi c'est ça
qu'est-ce qu'on met du palmarès
je pense que son caractère et son
parcours de vie fait de lui l'un des
plus grands joueurs de l'histoire
par contre c'est raté
un petit peu pendant la compétition si
vous parlez à quelqu'un qui aime
l'esthétisme et qui a vécu le foot des
années 70 il va vous dire creuse croyez
fait le plus grand joueur de tous les
temps alors qu'il a pas le palmarès de
Messi au Ronaldo
il faut voir les critères
alors selon vous ce soir il le devient
et ça l'était peut-être déjà Florent
selon vous qui est le plus grand joueur
de l'histoire du foot
c'est compliqué
de ne pas le plus grand joueur de
l'histoire du foot
ça se discute
on n'a pas vu tous les matchs Pelé donc
comment voulez-vous se positionner on
peut dire il faut faire les critères si
c'est les critères de stage
je sais pas pourquoi on a ce débat alors
que dans 10 ans on sera tous d'accord
que c'est qu'il est frappé
est-ce que première question est-ce que
Messie devient ce soir officiellement et
obligatoirement le meilleur joueur de
l'histoire du foot n'oublions moi je
pense que oui parce que je trouve qu'il
a il a aussi quand même il a la
révolutionné le football moi je trouve à
l'époque où il était à Barcelone un
moment donné moi je revois toutes ces
frappes à un moment donné on avait un
culte de la puissance des frappes lui ça
fait chirurgicale précis on avait
c'était énorme moi j'ai adoré après
c'était donc le joueur en termes de
charisme non mais
stricte point de vue footballistique
pour moi c'est le plus grand ouais
Vincent pour vous est-ce que Lionel
Messi ce soir devient le plus grand
joueur de l'histoire du foot c'est la
question qu'on pose sur Youtube ou
continuer à réagir et je vous donne la
réponse ici en plateau de ce sondage
Vincent vous en pensez quoi vous réponse
non non
on n'a pas avancé
évidemment
alors je vous donne la réponse oui oui à
76 % mais si devient ce soir le plus
grand joueur de l'histoire du foot
meilleur joueur de la compétition est-ce
que déjà il mérite ce titre c'est pas
une bataille mais avant de la
compétition
parce que pour moi c'est différent des
marquer des même si c'est vrai que ici a
marqué un but somptueux avec Alves mais
mais voilà enfin pour moi c'est Mbappé
mais je veux dire surtout vous avez mais
si cette buts trois pas décisives alors
certes il y a un wagon de de penalty
mais dans l'influence du jeu il a
vraiment porté l'Argentine et tout je
trouve que voilà
Mbappé il a fait une coupe du monde
extraordinaire mais par fulgurance mais
s'il a été influent sur l'ensemble des
matchs
en 8e en cas en 2000 et en finale si on
parle du beaujou et du fait d'avoir été
constante tous les langues et
l'influence etc dans ces cas-là c'est
Griezmann c'est pas ça on parle
de
disqualifications
c'est vraiment Mbappé
c'est Messi parce que toute l'équipe
d'Argentine a reposé sur lui on le voit
sur ce sur cette finale un moment donné
compte physiquement il pioche et quand
il s'éteint enfin il y a plus d'équipe
d'Argentine et à chaque fois qu'il s'est
éteint dans cette Coupe du Monde on a
plus vu l'équipe d'Argentine du tout
donc c'est ça a été le baromètre de son
épice
à chaque fois qu'elle plein des bus ça a
toujours été comme ça même quand elle
prenait pas de but dès que l'influence
Vincent est-ce que vous m'entendez oui
je vois que vous hochez la tête est-ce
que
ce soir le plus grand joueur de
l'histoire du foot
c'est une question très complexe mais je
ne sais pas je vous lirai oui je ne sais
que c'est compliqué parce que il y en a
tellement ça dépend tellement des
critères mais oui à ce qui est sûr c'est
que là il est rentré c'était l'un des
meilleurs c'est sûr et là il a ajouté
une pierre de plus on va dire une ligne
en plus à son CV pour être là devant
Pelé voilà moi j'ai pas vu jouer Pelé
donc je peux pas vraiment les comparer
j'ai vu quelques matchs mais c'est
compliqué quand même de de comparer en
tout cas oui c'est le meilleur joueur de
l'histoire récente et pour revenir par
contre sur le débat avant que vous
relancer sur ça mais sur sur le débat
meilleur joueur de cette coupe du monde
mais c'est Messi tous les jours en fait
il faut quand même se rappeler d'un truc
le match contre le Mexique l'Argentine
l'Argentine face aux face au Mexique
l'Argentine avait perdu son premier
match contre l'Arabie Saoudite le match
il est nul niveau niveau niveau argentin
et ils sont remettent à Messi qui marque
ce but qui les délivre et à partir de là
c'est ça qui change tout il a en fait il
a pris son équipe sur ses épaules il a
dit ok allez on y va et maintenant on va
gagner c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé et alors que pour Mbappe voilà il
y a Griezmann en fait voilà mais si
c'est un peu Mbappé et Griezmann en même
temps oui je vois ce que voulait dire
tout à fait j'entends
tous les jours comme si c'était non je
pense qu'il y a un débat il y a un débat
non il y a pas de débats
de la Coupe du monde alors que l'équipe
de France permet de doubler et une passe
décisive je l'entends je l'entends mais
voyez ce que fait Mbappé ce soir je suis
d'accord avec vous Messi mérite son type
de meilleur joueur pas largement devant
il a pas écrasé
le meilleur joueur du tournoi il y a il
y a eu une vraie des fois c'est c'est
tellement évident que c'est voilà un
joueur qui est nettement tu les autres
là il y a une finale extraordinaire et
il y a eu il y a eu un combat il y a eu
un duel exceptionnel
je peux pas vous donner raison quand
vous me dites c'est obligatoirement mais
si c'est à dire que si la séance de tir
au but bascule en fait pour moi c'est la
l'équipe qu'il y a donc ne me dites pas
qu'il y a pas débat regardez et à partir
du moment où Modric a été élu meilleur
Jean de la Coupe du Monde il y a 4 ans
il me semble hein pourtant il a perdu en
finale il avait été lu le meilleur
joueur de la Coupe du Monde et oui bon
en tout cas elle avait eu le Ballon d'Or
et ça ça fait aussi tant mieux c'est un
joueur exceptionnel mais bon
allez on a les images de Buenos Aires en
fait je pense qu'on va avoir des images
extraordinaires
surtout autour de la maison de la
grand-mère de Messi
maintenant dans une autre dans un autre
stade avant de regarder la France et en
Pays du football oui machin mais
maintenant avec ces matchs je pense
qu'ils vont se dire non la France a une
vraie stature on peut dire que c'est un
pays de football et on s'est là plus
respecté je pense l'Argentine de Lionel
Messi vient de soulever la Coupe du
Monde
argentin le numéro 10 et donc enfin
officiellement champion du monde on
continue à débattre de cette rencontre
on parle de Mbappé c'est paradoxal parce
que on disait Lionel Messi et peut-être
le plus grand joueur de l'histoire du
foot vous étiez semble-t-il d'accord et
le meilleur joueur de cette Coupe du
Monde est le meilleur joueur du monde
c'est Kylian Mbappé non aujourd'hui oui
aujourd'hui actuellement oui pour moi
c'est un contestable et les plus beaux
c'est qu'il a tellement de potentiels
parce que je pense qu'il peut encore
devenir meilleur à chaque fois il nous
surplombe davantage donc je pense que
bapé on a la chance de la voir je me
souviens qu'il a été très durement
critiqué quand il avait raté son prénom
à Lolo là je pense qu'il a fermé
quelques
parce que effectivement il montre qu'il
a vraiment les nerfs solides il peut
tenir ce genre de rencontre alors qu'il
n'a que 24 heures d'ailleurs il va avoir
son anniversaire c'est les 20 décembre
c'est bientôt donc en fait il en a
vraiment de quoi être fier après ce que
je peux vous dire également attendez je
voudrais qu'on aille au stade qu'on
écoute l'ambiance de ces feux d'artifice
ah il me semble qu'ils viennent de se
terminer c'est dommage c'est pas grave
on va retrouver une autre ambiance
Vincent sur place feu d'artifice ça y
est vous allez voir défaire les marais
Argentine sur vous et parlez-nous de
bapé il est lui aussi entré dans
l'histoire ce soir malgré la défaite
oui bien sûr il est rentré dans
l'histoire alors d'ailleurs le dernier
joueur qui a petit quiz le dernier
joueur a remis un triplet en finale de
Coupe du monde j'ai cherché c'était en
66 je me trompe pas
alors on a un problème on a un problème
donc je vois cette statistique on va me
la remontrer il a même Mbappé seulement
le deuxième joueur a réussi à tripler en
finale de Coupe du monde après Jeff East
avec l'Angleterre face à l'Allemagne en
66 voilà c'est ce que nous disait
Vincent Rozon non mais c'est incroyable
c'est-à-dire que on est mené de zéro et
pourtant on se dit on est on était
croyez moi j'ai du mal à y croire
honnêtement moi j'y croyais il y avait
des témoins non non mais se dit on se
dit quand il y a un joueur quand même un
peu mais comme quand il y a un joueur
comme Messi tout est possible et il fait
quand même un truc incroyable
c'est-à-dire qu'il marque quand même
trois penalty c'est à dire qu'il marque
les deux dans le jeu plus il est le
premier à tirer son tir au but
encore plus voilà et on a vu à quel
point c'était difficile de tirer deux
pelty coucou Harry
Kane mais c'est incroyable il a une
maturité et il a été incroyable moi je
trouve que on l'a vu 30 minutes mais on
est à 12 buts 12 buts en Coupe du monde
et donc il va avoir 24 ans dans deux
jours 12 buts je pense que ce soir c'est
lui le joueur le plus déçu le français
le plus beau le plus déçu dans ce monde
c'est lui on a vu un peu son visage Hugo
Lloris va forcément s'en vouloir Hugo
Lloris finalement
vous savez ce que veut Mbappé battre
tous les records oui et Lloris bon oui
évidemment il serait T10 à être double
champion du monde évidemment mais Mbappe
il veut battre tous les records il veut
battre peler et là ça se complique force
elle constater que trois Coupes du monde
et ça devient de plus en plus difficile
maintenant alors pour nous on s'est dit
on peut être fier de paper mais
effectivement
je sais que pour paper et même pour son
entourage c'était vraiment la victoire
c'est qu'il voulait c'était vraiment la
victoire évidemment que son entourage a
beaucoup de fierté mais un jour qu'on va
payer il faut comprendre son cerveau ne
marche pas comme les nôtres en fait
c'est vraiment c'est un dur c'est un
gagnant ou non
effectivement pour ça une défaite c'est
une défaite même si pour tout le monde
et le monde entier les diras qu'il a été
grandiose pour lui c'est une mais vous
verrez dans un mois un mois et demi deux
mois avec le PSG il sera de retour au
plus haut niveau avec cette je pense que
pour Lionel Messi ça aurait été plus
difficile
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent parce que
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux
notamment sur Youtube et sur le
Figaro.fr nous sommes au stade l'usaï au
Qatar avec Vincent roserand nous sommes
sur les Champs-Élysées un peu triste
sous la pluie avec Timothée tiens
Vincent je vous pose la question je
reviens vers vous qui viennent baper
est-ce que vous l'avez vu vous aussi
est-ce que vous l'avez vu triste plus
parce que les autres plus désemparé que
les autres après cette défaite
alors je vais pas vous mentir Thibault
on va pas mentir à notre spectateur
quand même mais je vous rappelle que je
sors du stade avant la fin du match donc
du coup
parce que vouloir sortir du stade pour
venir travailler dans un match comme ça
dans une séance de tir au but c'est
assez hallucinant Vincent oui c'est vrai
mais parlez-moi de son match
oui
oui bien sûr
qu'elle m'appelle alors rayonnant non 75
minutes c'est c'est il touche pas un
ballon on le voit de pas réussir alors
il a pas de ballon pour jouer mais en
fait vraiment c'est il marque ce penalty
et là le deuxième Ballon se dit quand il
arrive sur Lyon on se dit ben oui mais
en fait il va le mettre enfin c'est
qu'il est Mbappé alors que on aurait une
on aurait une n'importe qui derrière on
n'aurait pas pensé que forcément il
allait avoir but là on savait que ça
allait voir ça allait rentrer c'est là
où on se rend compte quand même que
Kylian Mbappe est un joueur exceptionnel
et voilà une finale de Coupe du Monde
gagné une finale de Coupe du Monde Perdu
et il a 23 ans il faut quand même s'en
rendre compte toujours
vous êtes un peu seul mais romain
coursier arrive dans un instant Vincent
je reste avec vous il commence à y avoir
du monde autour de vous ça y est le
stade se vide
ça y est c'est parti la cérémonie est
terminée il reste encore les les
supporters il y en a certains c'est sûr
qui sont restés dans le stade pour pour
célébrer leur équipe mais oui là vous
voyez tout autour de moi je pense que
vous voyez derrière moi aussi tout le
monde est en train de partir je vais
vous trouver des supporters français
d'ailleurs dans quelques instants si
vous voulez sans problème bien sûr on
attend les supporters français et des
supporters argentins si vous pouvez
parce que il faut les féliciter je pense
qu'ils sont heureux mais vous m'avez dit
qu'ils veulent rester encore dans ce
stade je pense que les les stadiers
Qatariens vont avoir du mal à les faire
sortir romain coursier journaliste
réseaux sociaux j'ai retrouvé votre voix
je voulais sortir un peu énervé pendant
le match hein comme nous tous après tout
fébrile on doit passer 75 minutes très
compliqué puis après la folie
personnellement oui on peut on peut
complètement féliciter les Argentins
alors vous nous montrez ce qu'il s'est
passé sur les réseaux sociaux
racontez-moi tout ça alors justement on
va repartir au début du match un début
du match très compliqué le hashtag qui a
été plébiscité par les internaute sur
cette première mi-temps c'était
catastrophique ah oui je pense que c'est
un hashtag de raison
compliqué là donc on voit ce truc voilà
c'est une image des Simpsons qui résume
bien la première mi-temps de l'équipe de
France et nous devant notre télévision
et ben on est tous circonspect personnel
parce que parce que en fait c'est rien
du côté de l'équipe de France tout
simplement un joueur qui symbolise cette
cette catastrophe
Ousmane Dembélé
peut-être le plus cataclysmique alors
vous voyez deux salles de ambiances le
premier qui dit Dembélé c'est pas ta
faute mon grand c'est truqué c'est bon
comme pour dire le Penji avait pas
vraiment penalty et l'autre les 40
minutes 12 semaines Dembélé mérite un
passage à Fleury-Mérogis
les deux sont
un tout petit peu excessif mais voilà on
comprend ça a été vraiment très
compliqué oui je trouve moins excessif
le premier mais le deuxième est un peu
violent bon mais vous avez raison c'est
ce que pense les réseaux sociaux je vous
laisse continuer bon quand même je pense
que il était critiquable ensuite voilà
tout ça et sur le temps de l'humour
évidemment évidemment si on revient sur
un match un match incroyable quel match
vous voyez et le dernier tweet qui
revient sur l'homme peut-être l'homme du
match et alors vraiment là qu'on ne
pensait pas voir briller autant Randall
colo moignon
dans un instant allez-y je laisse
continuer en toi et son entrée le voilà
c'est là où le match est complètement
basculé et basculer dans dans la folie
bon je vous laisse continuer à les dire
romain
et ben on enchaîne avec le premier
triplet en finale de Coupe du Monde
depuis 1966 donc ça avait déjà été fait
mais là Mbappe dans tous les livres
d'histoire
c'est fou et si on gagne moi je vous dis
vraiment si on gagne il aurait il aurait
il aurait fait du monde d'affilée
triplés
par rapport à Messi vous êtes l'ombre à
Messi rien que sur sur deux éditions de
Coupe du Monde d'affilée donc un grand
bravo quand même à Kylian Mbappe il a
été très discret on va pas se mentir
pendant les 70 premières minutes comme
l'équipe de France mais quand il est
sorti de sa boîte ça fait trois buts et
le hashtag qui est aussi revient pas mal
c'est le fameux tu es pas content doublé
qui devient t'es pas content triplés
attendez on explique la référence parce
que c'est une interview de Kylian Mbappé
hier il y a quelques années il est assez
jeune et il dit moi je veux toujours
marqué et voilà tu es pas content boum
elle est géniale c'est sa mentalité et
là c'est vrai que il a dû il a dû faire
un petit peu rouspéter sur Hugo Lloris
Hugo Lloris ah oui alors Hugo Lloris qui
a fait une très bonne très bonne
compétition mais alors parce que on va
le critiquer je sens on va le critiquer
sur les les buts ils s'en prend plein la
tête c'est des supporters déçus qui
voulaient voir l'équipe de France la
parade qu'il fait sur Lionel Messi oui
euh à la 89e minute il me semble
et alors juste avant le but de Messi
l'arrêt qu'il fait en prolongation
incroyable aussi pardon pour moi il y a
rien à dire sur Hugo Lloris forcé de
constater que voilà les tirs buts ça a
été l'occasion pour pour ceux qui ne
sont pas fan du golioris de le critiquer
Loris c'est le pire gardien de
l'histoire au penalty elle adresse de
d'échange j'aurais fait rentrer
65 millions de sélectionneurs on a
toujours la bonne réponse quand ça s'est
mal passé pour nous bien sûr mais bon
nous on peut quand même féliciter la
Hugo Lloris sur sa sur sa compétition ce
qu'on a les petites courbes là les
diagrammes et tout et vous connaissez
bien la chronique
effectivement la courbe du match avec
donc là on était de toute façon sur des
niveaux de poste extrêmement élevés
est-ce que dans un match comme ça on est
dans le niveau de poste le plus
important de l'histoire ou presque
quasiment non je voudrais pas vous dire
de bêtises Thibault mais moi j'ai jamais
vu ça d'accord c'est certain alors
expliquez-moi cette courbe parce qu'elle
est pas toujours compréhensible de nos
internautes et c'est assez passionnant
donc cette courbe elle nous dit combien
de postes ont été faits sur le réseau
sociaux en fonction des minutes des
minutes du match donc on va dire que sur
sur les premières minutes il s'est pas
passé grand chose dès le premier but de
Leo Messi on passe la barre des 100000
postes minutes deuxième but de Di Maria
c'est un peu moins puisque forcément
c'est un petit peu toujours la même
émotion c'était une maîtrise totale de
l'Argentine après on s'endort un peu
hein quand même exactement on s'endort
un petit peu on va dire que ça se
réveille un peu à la mi-temps parce que
c'est aussi là où euh
le plus petit
la première poste et alors là c'est une
seule un seul pic sur les deux buts de
Mbappe ils ont été tellement rapprochés
qu'il y a un seul pied qui ont frôlé 150
000 ensuite il y a 150 000 postes 150
minutes minutes on repasse la barre des
100000 sur le but de Messi puis sur le
triplet de Mbappé et alors à la victoire
de l'Argentine voilà c'est 300000 postes
minutes en même temps c'est la finale de
la Coupe du Monde assez hallucinant et
alors de quel genre on a le plus parlé
alors sur les joueurs français c'est pas
une grosse surprise c'est qu'il y a
Mbappe
de la tête et les épaules les mentions
de joueurs français le deuxième c'est
Ousmane Dembélé donc à priori plutôt
pour le critiquer et ensuite bah voilà
Giroud je pensais son remplacement
quelques quelques polémiques et quand
même une gars qui fait aussi une grosse
rentrée pas de Colomiers non un petit
injustice pour Randall qui fait quand
même la meilleure rentrée de tout le
match allez on parle justement de
Randall colomani et avant ça on va voir
Vincent roseron sur place qui avec un
supporter de l'équipe de France vous
avez la main Vincent
mais bon après
oui alors effectivement avec un
supporter de l'équipe de France qui me
disait qu'il était quand même un peu
déçu de ce qui va se passer forcément on
a vécu un match de légende je pense que
s'il y avait une finale à laquelle il
fallait être je pense que c'est celle-ci
est vraiment c'était exceptionnel j'ai
je suis passé par toutes les émotions
débute les tirs au but les prolongations
c'était c'était incroyable bon avec un
dénouement triste pour nous mais c'est
le football c'est c'est comme ça qui
c'est que vous avez envie de retenir
dans ce match qu'il a même pas pu avec
son triplet ah oui oui Killian avec son
triplé évidemment qu'il y a Mbappé mais
surtout des champs qui franchement a
réussi à faire des choix très difficiles
en sortant Giroud et Dembélé dans la
première mi-temps c'est des choix très
compliqués ensuite Il fait sortir
Griezmann qui est peut-être notre
meilleur joueur sur la compétition et le
fait sortir en deuxième alors qu'on est
en train de perdre et là ces choix sont
payants donc grand coaching de déchets
Mbappé je pense que ce mec là il finira
jamais de nous étonner évidemment que
et donc forcément voilà il y a des
supporters argentins qui sont en train
mais bon elle va payer il a 23 ans il
est encore le monde devant lui il a fait
une guerre de dingue vous rendez compte
23 ans une fille avec gagner une fille à
la Coupe du Monde Perdu et 4 buts déjà
en finale la Coupe du Monde c'est c'est
exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel vraiment
et je pense que il finira jamais de nous
étonner après bon évidemment les
supporters de Messi
vas-y les supporters argentins et Messi
qui qui est bien sûr je pense que Messi
on est tous d'accord pour dire que c'est
le meilleur joueur de l'histoire il
méritait sa coupe du monde évidemment
après je suis déçu quand même pour pour
l'équipe de France ce soir et Mbappe
aura la chance de prouver que lui aussi
que ça soit la table de Messi et de
Cristiano des joueurs comme ça et bien
on espère merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous voilà Thibault
donc voilà les supporters forcément
déçus après ce match même si oui on a
vécu dans ce stade de l'ouzaï locataire
un match de légende complètement j'en ai
besoin derrière vous qui était pas déçu
et il voulait bien fait comprendre je le
comprends le supporter argent par
Vincent du chêne au service de son merci
d'être ici tiens je pose cette question
sur le Figaro quel sentiment domine
après la rencontre de l'équipe de France
est-ce que c'est la tristesse ou la
fierté hein c'est vrai on peut se poser
la question tiens pour vous Cédric
là maintenant la tristesse de la fierté
et vous Cindy
je suis encore comme un boxeur là je
suis groggy par par les coups qu'on a
pris là
pour l'instant allez on parle de Randal
lemonie s'il vous plaît parce que c'est
peut-être l'homme du match d'une
certaine manière puisqu'il a fait
basculer la rencontre par son intensité
et puis
cette action à la 80 quoi 13e 14e 16e
minute peut-être cette frappe est
l'arrêt incroyable d'Emiliano Martinez
tiens Vincent je vous donne la parole
puisque vous venez d'arriver en Alco le
Monica elle rencontre ce soir je pense
qu'il est rentré dans le coeur des
Français parce qu'on verra les audiences
demain sur TF1 je pense qu'il y a un
paquet de monde dans ce pays qui la
découverte ce soir bah déjà qu'il était
buteur en demi-finale c'était assez
inattendu et là il fait une rentrée
c'est lui qui nous qui nous relance
parce qu'il amène son peps il amène son
énergie alors qu'on était totalement
totalement
le bidon on va le dire comme ça pendant
75 minutes et il nous a fait du bien et
au final il est pasteur décisif parce
que c'est lui qui fait la passe pour
pour Mbappe sur la remise donc il fait
il fait vraiment un super match et il y
a cette occasion et je crois que c'est
en toute fin de match de la prolongation
que qui fait la Reine des Neiges
il me semble ce sont les notes on va
dire dans l'oreillette des joueurs qui
sont entrés en jeu coman Thuram
camavinga ah est-ce qu'on peut me
remonter Colomiers j'ai pas eu le temps
on a donné une meilleure note à Kama
vinga euh il me semble que c'est ça huit
ou si j'arrive pas à 65 donc c'est bien
ça que le mois 17 Cédric le match de
Colombie on en parle ah oui non il était
extraordinaire c'est alors
habituellement quand on a des
compétitions comme des Coupes du Monde
ou des euros on parle de tubes de l'été
bon là ça va être le tube de l'hiver
quand le mois de mai encore une fois
c'est à dire que sous le sapin de Noël
c'est le maillot qui aura le plus
c'est ça donc là à mon avis il va
falloir qu'il fasse quelques flocages
parce que ça c'était pas prévu non et je
suis euh non non il fait une rentrée
extraordinaire alors c'est vrai qu'il y
avait quelques actions il fait une
rentrée extraordinaire dans ce match une
rentrée extraordinaire dans cette équipe
de France aussi ouais on peut rappeler
ce qu'il s'est passé au début et ben
normalement il aurait pas dû en être il
a remplacé Christopher nkounku donc au
départ au départ on a le Colombiers on
aurait pas dû au repas du être là il
aurait dû être devant sa télévision et
ça aurait été bien dommage pour nous ce
soir est-ce que vous vous souvenez il y
a quelques mois de ça on faisait un live
ici tous les deux sur ce plateau pour
connaître la liste Didier Deschamps la
Ligue des Nations il me semble et nous
avions vu apparaître au dernier moment
on est en train de discuter le nom de
Randall colomania
franchement
que le bonus dans cette équipe de France
avouez qu'on s'était dit ça tous les cas
bien sûr puis même même là c'est vrai
que quand il le fait rentrer en
demi-finale il y a toujours un petit un
petit commentaire un petit peu ironique
voilà on se dit mais mais il faut
reconnaître qu'il a su saisir sa chance
c'est que maintenant je pense qu'il va
vraiment
prendre sa place dans la
hiérarchie de Didier deschampsie Didier
Deschamps décident de continuer
maintenant non non ils sont enthousiasme
c'est ça qui fait plaisir et c'est vrai
qu'il est voilà c'est une finale de
Coupe du Monde il sait pas caché il y a
été et ça a été c'était vraiment une
belle découverte mais pas que lui il y a
eu le double le double remplacement avec
avec Marcus Thuram fait beaucoup de bien
en fait et même ensuite que Mavinga tous
les rentrants étaient bons tout le
coaching de Didier Deschamps était bon
il a il a eu un nombre de galères pas
possible sur cette compétition et et
faut vraiment lui rendre hommage parce
qu'il a été extraordinaire comme
sélectionneur évidemment on va aller
dans sur les Champs-Élysées dans un
instant retrouver Timothée delaime pour
savoir quel est l'ambiance sur place et
oui ça bug pour l'instant mais c'est pas
grave on va le retrouver Cindy
Colmenares parlez-moi de Randal
colomanie match exceptionnel ce soir
il est devenu en tout cas dans cette
compétition et dans cette finale et puis
surtout je trouve que pour plusieurs qui
manque autant d'expériences en équipe de
France sont quand même avoir cette
solidité et puis vraiment il aurait pu
nous changer les visages des des
settylos parce que si il y avait eu
d'autres illobus pour la France c'est
lui en fait qui a entamé ces bonnes
c'est bon je suis tard en fait donc il
aurait pu nous sauver les matchs
pas du tout facile donc je pense que
Martinez
qu'il appelle comment
des Sud-Américains
il y en a d'autres dans cette équipe
[Rires]
on fera les notes d'ailleurs tiens je
vous donne le petit programme de ce qui
nous attend parce qu'on reste encore un
moment ensemble on attend la réaction du
président de la République qui était au
stade qui était même sur la pelouse on
l'a vu longuement
essayer de réconforter Kilian Mbappé on
écoutera le président dans dans un
instant mais tiens voilà le président de
la République je vous propose de
l'écouter ensemble c'est un bon résumé
c'est ce que j'ai dit au joueur un
instant c'est on est d'abord très triste
tous déçus comme après une une défaite
et surtout comme ça parce qu'on est
passé si près du but et en même temps ce
que j'ai dit à tous les joueurs un
instant dans le vestiaire c'est qu'il
nous avait rendu immensément fier et qui
nous avait fait vibrer et je pense c'est
une des plus grandes une des plus
grandes finales de Coupe du monde que
nous avons tous vécu
est-ce que vous avez compris le seul
président cette obscurité est d'un seul
coup cette lumière ils étaient dans le
noir pendant 80 minutes je suis ni jouer
en Nico
je suis
je suis président
les joueurs moi j'ai pas les juger ils
nous ont du Fier ce qui est vrai c'est
que soyons clairs on est on était très
très loin à la fin de la première
mi-temps
je pense que c'est déjà arrivé il y a eu
des remontada comme ça à l'Allemagne en
54 ou des choses comme ça mais c'est
très rare dans l'histoire du foot et on
est remonté formidablement il y a eu
ça fait un triplet c'est pas arrivé
depuis 1966
a eu un seul coup on a retrouvé la fin
voilà et donc il y a eu à partir de la
6065e une équipe qui a retrouvé la fin
qui a envie il y avait un moment qui
était là moi j'ai immensément cru j'ai
cru qu'on allait marquer avant la fin du
temps réglementaire j'ai cru qu'on
allait marquer les premiers pendant les
prolongations et après on a fait un
deuxième miracle on est revenu de nulle
part parce que revenir d'un 32 en
prolongation c'est très rare et on la
refait et on a eu malgré tout ça on a eu
la balle de match elle était dans nos
pieds
il avait que 24 ans
et donc qu'est-ce que je voulais que je
vous dis il est il a été meilleur buteur
de cette coupe il est un joueur
extraordinaire il est il a déjà gagné
une Coupe du Monde il fait une finale
voilà donc il a que 24 ans et je le dis
franchement je suis pas le mieux placé
pour essayer de raisonner ce soir les
gens parce que j'étais au moins aussi
triste que lui vous leur avez dit quoi
dans le vestiaire c'est un qui nous
avait rendu très fier et qu'à la fin
évident d'ailleurs comme quand on a
perdu un match de foot et surtout qu'on
est passé rien et puis j'ai vu des gens
tellement tristes l'instant ouais bien
sûr et donc mais c'est tout c'est le
sport aussi et donc je félicite l'équipe
d'Argentine parce que c'est un très
grand peuple de sport c'est un très
grandple de foot et que voilà il y a des
il y a des moments où on gagne des
matchs mythiques au tir au but on en a
gagné on en a perdu aussi moi je me
souviens plus jeune et celui là on a
perdu ils ont gagné donc bravo à
l'Argentine aux argentins et leur
peuples ils étaient là en masse et nous
ça nous ça nous rend triste ce soir mais
on peut être fier de notre équipe parce
que c'est très rare d'avoir en ayant
gagné une Coupe de revenir d'aller en
phase finale et de quasiment gagner
des champs de poursuivre je veux qu'il
poursuivre moi j'ai dit à Didier
Deschamps qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
digère et puis j'ai surtout dit Oh voilà
nos joueurs qui pouvaient parfois
nourrir des regrets ce soir parce que
c'est très dur imaginez-vous pour des
tout jeune qui qui voilà mettent pas de
penalty au moins de le mettre tout ce
qui se passe dans la tête et donc je
leur ai surtout dit
faut le digérer et regarder
on en a un ce soir qui en a marqué trois
qui est un immense joueur il est arrivé
de rater des penalties il a digéré c'est
ça qui fait les très grands joueurs et
donc on est une grande nation de foot on
est aussi une grande nation tout court
qui était derrière son équipe qui est
forte et est-ce que ce match nous dit
aussi c'est qu'il y a jamais de scénario
écrit d'avance que c'est toujours
possible moi chaque fois qu'on s'est
pris un budget debout pour dire on
repart j'ai essayé de leur de crier on
repart on prend le ballon et on va
remarquer donc tout est possible si on
se tient une ici on est ensemble s'il y
a de la volonté du talent c'est ce qui a
montré cette équipe à la fin on n'a pas
de chance ok c'est encore plus rageant
et triste ok il y a des tas de Momo qui
pleurent il y a des tas de gens qui
pleurent ce soir et on est triste c'est
vrai mais elle a montré du cœur et de
l'unité c'est ça l'image de la France
mais c'est pas je suis je suis pas
président de fédération de foot je suis
pas dans la tête de Didier Deschamps
enfin Didier Deschamps il a montré qu'il
était une fois encore un immense
sélectionné est-ce que vous allez
recevoir ces joueurs à l'Elysée tout de
même alors demain je serai avec nos
soldats mais je recevrai ces joueurs ils
vont rentrer ils vont être auprès des
Françaises et des Français descendre les
Champs-Élysées et moi ils vont faire ça
demain ça c'est eux de dire le programme
c'est la Fédération qu'il dira et moi
j'avais de toute façon quelque soit le
scénario de ce soir prévu d'être demain
auprès de nos soldats pour faire Noël en
avance comme chaque année et leur dire
la solidarité de la nation voilà mais
vous et je serai aux côtés de ces
joueurs et c'est prévu je crois dans
quelques semaines ou quelques mois en
fonction de leur propre calendrier voilà
en tout cas je veux que toutes celles et
ceux qui nous écoutent ce soir et qui
sont tristes leur dire que je partage
leur tristesse mais qu'on peut être fier
de cette équipe il faut pas l'oublier il
faut être et qu'elle dit aussi quelque
chose de ce que nous sommes profondément
d'une capacité à remonter et de plus fou
de créer l'impensable d'être uni et
d'avoir des talents géniaux en quelque
sorte
c'est la résistance l'exploit c'est
voilà donc vive la république et vive la
France c'est comme ça que j'ai fini mon
speecho vestiaire vive la république et
vive la france merci beaucoup
voilà la déclaration du Président de la
République avec ce mot qui est revenu
plusieurs fois on doit être fier la
fierté et d'ailleurs c'est la question
que je vous posez sur Youtube quel
sentiment de ce soir la fierté ou la
tristesse et pour l'instant c'est la
fierté 509 % voilà
la politique n'est jamais bien loin mais
le président de la République et quand
même un bon connaisseur de foot je pense
que vous en pensez
la France avait gagné ses matchs c'était
historique parce que ça veut dire que
sous son mandat il y aurait eu deux
Coupes du monde donc voilà la Coupe du
Monde exactement sauf que là ils sont
quand même finalistes
puisqu'on est en 2022 2027 c'est encore
possible pourquoi pas
je pense que c'est vraiment atteignable
pour l'équipe de France qu'on voit
aujourd'hui alors deux finales
consécutives de victoire consécutives ça
s'est pas vu depuis euh
depuis 62 en revanche trois finales
consécutifs c'est vu plusieurs fois
l'Allemagne l'a fait 82 86 82 ils en ont
perdu 90 et le Brésil aussi 94 98 2002
ils ont gagné la première à la 3e donc
trois finales consécutives c'est
possible bon voilà on a entendu le
président de la République qui parlait
des Champs-Élysées et des Bleus qui
demain devraient
descendre les champs on verra s'il y a
s'il y a du monde pour lundi en plein
hiver et attendons de voir en tout cas
il y a Timothée Delem pour l'instant qui
est sur le champs il reste toute la nuit
et demain matin vous bougez pas timoto
vous apera du café et pour l'instant les
Champs-Élysées sont désespérément vides
oui on espère qu'il y aura plus de monde
demain si les Bleus sont amenés à
descendre les Champs-Élysées en tous les
cas vous le voyez sur ces images de
Romario peu de monde peu de bruit
également sur les Champs-Élysées
actuellement les supporters de l'équipe
de France qui sont en train petit à
petit d'évacuer d'évacuer les lieux
alors que les policiers eux demandent en
fait aux gens d'évacuer la chaussée
pourquoi et bien parce que tout
simplement les choses vont être rouverts
à la circulation c'était prévu en cas de
victoire que la circulation soit fermée
jusqu'à 4h du matin finalement voilà les
événements malheureux pour l'équipe de
France on fait que voilà les la
circulation va être ouverte sur les
Champs-Élysées les supporteurs eux sont
en train et bien de regagner tout
simplement leur leur maison leurs
appartements et voilà l'ambiance ici qui
reste qui reste plutôt bonne enfance
sous le regard des des policiers
évidemment mais voilà toujours sous la
pluie en plus mais vous le voyez c'est
supporter autour de moi qui qui garde le
sourire et qui ont un message tu as
passé pour les joueurs de l'équipe de
France nouveaux armes très frais de vous
malgré la défaite vous êtes les gens peu
pour nous on vous aime nous sommes très
fiers de vous
voilà Thibault pour ces supporters qui
gardent le sourire ouais vous avez
raison de toute façon il faut et il y a
pas trop le choix évidemment tiens on
parle de
on fait les notes d'abord on les fait
rapidement on fait les notes après on
parlera Didier Deschamps alors s'il doit
continuer avec cette équipe de France
tiens Vincent roseron on commence par
vous Hugo Lloris vous lui donnez quelle
note ce soir
7 juin 7 parce qu'il peut pas grand
chose sur les bus qui prend quand même
dont le troisième où il fait une parade
absolument incroyable vraiment et sur le
reste du match c'est lui qui tient les
qui qui tient les Bleus à flots aucune
erreur après voilà il y a cette séance
de penalty c'est compliqué de mettre un
7 un gardien qui arrête aucun tir au but
mais bon vraiment match de titan pour
moi gros gros match de d'Hugo Lloris qui
a été l'un des seuls cadres finalement à
répondre présent
Hugo Lloris qui était bon à part sur les
sur les tirs au but Cédric vous lui
donnez combien
même constat il fait des arrêts décisifs
il est pas des trois buts qui prend
c'est pas de sa responsabilité j'aurais
même mis 8 on va dire et puis descend à
7 pour la pour la séance
dans le temps dans les 120 minutes du
match aussi je vois pas pourquoi je vois
pas quelle erreur il fait sur un début
et il sort trois ou quatre très belles
parades donc bon 7 pour rigoler vous
vous lui donnez combien les amis sur le
sur le canapé moi je mettrai 6 parce que
malheureusement il est pas décisif lors
de la séance de tir au but et c'est ça
qui fait la différence au final quoi
dans une finale comme ça si ça avait été
un match ordinaire
mais par rapport au fait que il a été
très bon effectivement pendant tous les
matchs mais qui est Kany avait besoin
malheureusement ça c'est pas bien passé
après il y avait des en face qui était
très bas
Martinez je l'ai mis si c'est demi j'ai
posé la question sur Youtube quelle date
de dévot à Kilian Mbappé puisqu'on va
remonter tranquillement jusqu'à lui j'ai
mis quatre options je suis pas descendu
en dessous de 7 10 9 8 7 vous nous dites
vous cliquez et on en parle après allez
la défense
Jules kunday combien vous lui donnez on
fait kunder rapidement il a pas été mal
ensemble il a quand même Di Maria lui a
fait quand même danser le tango pendant
un bon moment donc
j'ai oublié les enfants 65 minutes il
était en grande difficulté donc 4 4
je donne la moyenne c'était un match
difficile et il a aussi été porté on va
dire vers les bas par les autres membres
de l'équipe qui était pas non plus au
niveau
allez on enchaîne cette défense centrale
on les fait ensemble ou pas mécano
Varane j'ai l'impression de couper
mécano a été très bon moi je mettrai une
bonne note Varane a eu plus de mal hein
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez tiens
je commence avec vous Vincent quelle
note vous donner à chacun des deux
ou pas mécano je mettrai un 6 et Varane
je mettrai un 4 et il est quand même
assez fautif sur les deux buts
j'ai peur que le virus qui a eu varan
est quand même eu on l'a vu finir mais
complètement exténué mais moi je
mettrais peut-être quatre et demi à
Varane et si ça vous permettez
ou pas mécano a été très
bons qui devaient avoir il a su
comprendre quel type de match il était
en train de jouer donc je lui donne une
bonne note on va dire un 7 et par
rapport à Varane
je veux des envies quand même mais bon
c'est pour ça qu'on va mettre en quatre
et demi je rejoins Cédric il avait des
langues mais il a plus de difficultés
on se demande comment c'est possible
quoi
4 ans et demi et ou pas mécano moi je me
souviens de son tac le Salvateur ou
justement on s'est dit ça ça vaut un but
ça parce que c'est exceptionnel
ou pas mécano en effet Vincent vous avez
raison c'est la note qu'on donnait
Baptiste des Prés et Christophe remise
dans le stade j'avais mis trois à
Raphaël
vous lui donnez combien ah là je lui
donne 3 ah oui vous avez pas aimé
catastrophique oui c'est vrai et alors
les 25 premières minutes et même
offensivement
dont certains sur des passes totalement
anodines et des situations où il y avait
pas d'énormes pressing argentin donc
voilà forcément il a rien apporté
défensivement
il a souffert aussi dans cette
catastrophe et l'équipe de France a été
devant lui donc voilà dites-moi Vincent
je vous ai vu faire un petit geste vous
lui donnez combien avec les doigts là
qui passe complètement à côté de ton
match qui réussit rien qui qui a pas
réussi un bon centre et et le meilleur
joueur à ce poste là sur ce sur cette
finale c'est cavavigak qui ne joue pas
du tout à ce poste là donc voilà c'est
il avait pas l'envie non plus on a
l'impression il était complètement cramé
en fait tu as c'était très grave match
très très compliqué pour lui ouais pas
plus de 3 je suis d'accord avec vous
mais Cavavin gay est entré dans une
période où l'équipe de France allait
bien aussi peut-être qu'il a contribué à
cela mais où il y a beaucoup plus
d'espace ou mais si c'est un peu et
d'ailleurs je nous envoyer spécial lui
ont donné 6 à venir donner 4 à Théo
Hernandez ouais 4 aussi pour vous et
pour moi 4 et je trouve que son erreur
il a été méconnaissable dans ses matchs
mais c'est vrai que des Hernandez ça a
été celui qui était mis dans la Coupe du
Monde il a été très bon pendant tout le
long du monde du Mondial donc on avait
plus de spectative par rapport à lui
donc je pense que à ce niveau il nous a
déçu et c'est pour ça que c'est 4 vous
continuez à voter et donner votre note à
Kylian Mbappe sur le de YouTube 1987 on
va voir ce qu'on pense aux internautes
je vous donne pas tout de suite la
réponse on remonte au milieu de terrain
alors la note du duo
choixmeni rabiot combien vous leur
donnez Cédric choix béni 4
rabiot
rabiot il est monté en puissance parce
que en première période je lui ai mis
deux mais après en seconde période et il
a il a su se remettre dedans pareil moi
je mettrai ça un carabio et 5 à 5
carabio 7 non c'est ça quatre à trois
mini quatre arabios c'est ce qu'ils ont
donné ce que vous êtes d'accord ils ont
pas été très bon et puis ils se sont
fait manger pendant 70 minutes quoi
à un moment de mettre le pied sur le
ballon et de dire
que les Bleus étaient un peu inexistants
c'était c'est au milieu que ça avait des
difficultés ça penchait après
j'ai des difficultés à noter Fabio je
voulais dit très franchement parce qu'il
a fait une très belle coupe du monde
mais on va quand même être sortir
complètement vidée
4 parce qu'il est passé complètement à
côté de sa finale et puis en plus il y
aura un penaud il rate le cadre
largement ça c'est ça c'est
inadmissible
voilà celui de coman à la limite il est
quand même cadré ça mais en effet quand
on rate un penal à côté 4 c'est presque
c'est presque gentiment conseiller
l'exercice n'était pas facile pour
l'injure avec si peu d'expérience il a
fait une bonne coupe du monde mais le
lanteront pas voilà on compte sur lui
mais voilà mais là sur ce marché j'ai
une petite statistique sachez que cette
édition de la Coupe du monde et la plus
prolifique en but de l'histoire 172 buts
marqués en 2022
c'est un de plus que lors des Coupe du
Monde 98 et 2014 donc
ça restera dans l'histoire puisque la
prochaine Coupe du Monde on jouera avec
98 équipes donc ça sera plus les mêmes
stats c'est pas sûr encore
Antoine Griezmann Saint Vincent vous lui
donnez quelle note il est passé à côté
de son match le métronome des Bleus non
ouais c'est compliqué du mettre plus de
3 ou 4 vraiment il a été complètement
serré après d'un côté il faut le dire
aussi je pense que le le système
argentin enfin parce qu'on parlait tout
à l'heure Didier Deschamps je sais qu'on
va pas être forcément noter Didier
Deschamps mais en fait le coach argentin
a gagné son duel face à des champs en
fait dès le début du match c'est c'est
vrai qu'ils ont le joueur c'est aussi
une question de système ils étaient en
supériorité numérique au milieu de
terrain et tu vas venir à bio Griezmann
ils ont pas existé à cause à cause de ça
et effectivement Griezmann du coup je
sais pas à 3 et demi et alors on va
noter des chances intéressantes parce
que moi je lui donnerai finalement une
très bonne note à des champs au final
même si rate le début ce qu'il fait
après les choix qu'il fait son excellent
la note je vous la donne celle de
Griezmann ils ont donné trois à nos amis
nos amis sur le
ça il faut regarder
Cindy alors on note un match
là pour les coups je vous parle de match
je vais vous dire pourquoi je voulais
dire
vous m'entendez pas non je vous ai dit
que la tactique de ce qu'on a pu lire
dans ces matchs d'escalomie c'était
vraiment des maîtriser du côté de
Griezmann et quand vous avez tous les
joueurs qui sont un peuplés sur glaceman
effectivement c'est plus difficile pour
lui donc c'est pas qu'il a fait un
mauvais match c'est qu'il essayait de
faire comme d'habitude des casser les
lignes mais les gens là-bas
Cindy attendez ils étaient tous sur
Griezmann mais j'ai l'impression que
c'était tout aussi sur Mbappé puis ils
étaient tous sur Giroud et puis ils les
ont à se fixé et en plus de ça ils ont
mis la tête
non habituellement c'est Griezmann
les génies d'escalomie c'est d'avoir
compris cela et d'avoir une neutraliser
Griezmann donc ce n'est pas un mauvais
jeu
compliqué pour lui parce que les autres
ne suivaient pas nous Griezmann c'est
que même le premier quart d'heure de la
seconde période où l'équipe de France
commençait à ressortir un peu la tête de
l'eau on ne l'a toujours pas vu et moi
je l'ai vu plusieurs fois marcher on
avait l'impression qu'il était mais
après il a tellement donné sur les
autres matchs il fait une coupe du monde
extraordinaire donc voilà mais
pour l'instant parce que je précise que
nous sommes sur les Champs-Élysées on
voit les forces de l'ordre qui avancent
alors on sait que les champs doivent
être rouverts à la circulation c'est ce
que nous expliquer il y a un sentimenté
de l'aime on espère que ça se passera
dans le calme évidemment mais c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça qu'on voit cette
avancée des forces de l'ordre qui sont
en train de rouvrir la plus belle avenue
du monde en espérant que tout ça se
déroule dans le calme voilà pour notre
débat sur Griezmann il y en a un qui l'a
remplacé c'est Kingsley coman tiens euh
lui il a fait du bien quand même moi je
lui donnerai une bonne note pour le coup
on rentre on est frais on a une porte de
l'affiche à l'équipe de France c'est ce
qu'il fallait donc là vous donner une
bonne note à Didier Deschamps absolument
c'est une excellente mode
contre la Tunisie où il est pas bon du
tout où il n'a pas pris finalement la
place Dembélé alors s'il y avait une
ouverture parce que Dembélé a pas fait
une bonne Coupe du monde
et là il a montré qu'il pouvait être
c'est un très grand jeu également donc
on attendait
n'a pas été noté puisqu'il n'a pas joué
45 minutes
[Musique]
a été noté on en a parlé tout à l'heure
la note de 7 il a été donnée Olivier
Giroud n'a pas joué 45 minutes donc il
n'est pas une idée
chrétienne
remplacé par Marcus Thuram 6 et nous
ouvrons donc la page Kilian Mbappé
lorsqu'on met un triplet en finale de
Coupe du monde mérite-t-on à 10 ouais
le petit argument n'a pas gagné le match
Vincent Rozon vous avez la parole Kylian
Mbappe mérite-t-il à 10 ce soir ou non
et ben je vais essayer de pas me faire
taper dessus par Cindy Colmena S mais je
dirais non moi je mettrai un neuf en
fait je sais pas comment dire il arrive
forcément à changer le cours du match
parce que il marque le penal si bon
c'est un penalty voilà la deuxième
Ballon comme je vous le dis on sait
qu'on voit que c'est on voit qu'il va
que c'est lui on se dit bah oui
forcément ça va rentrer et tout et
ensuite il remarque ce troisième penal
ce deuxième penalty il met ce troisième
but un triple en finale c'est magnifique
mais il y a pas la victoire au bout déjà
et ça c'est quand même le gros problème
pour son CV je pense donc oui pour moi
je suis désolé ce sera neuf pas plus que
ça continue sur Kilian Mbappé je
voudrais qu'on retrouve Timothée
Delhaize mais est-ce qu'on a T2M parce
qu'il est sur les Champs-Élysées
l'impression que ça s'échauffe un peu
mais je ne veux pas dire de bêtises donc
Timothée si vous m'entendez vous avez la
parole et expliquez-moi ce qui se passe
sur les champs
quelques quelques tensions effectivement
Thibault ce qui se passe c'est que les
policiers sont en train de remonter les
Champs-Élysées depuis la place Roosevelt
jusqu'à l'Arc de Triomphe pour et bien
évacuer la voix pour pouvoir la réouvrir
aux voitures c'est ce qu'ils viennent de
nous expliquer à l'instant même mais
voilà quelques tensions en cours avec
des feux d'artifice qui ont été lancés
contre les véhicules de la police
nationale qui est remonté les
Champs-Élysées il y a eu quelques
charges de CRS et voilà quelques
tensions mais pour l'instant la
situation reste malgré tout maîtrisée
vous les voyez peut-être sur ces images
de Romain Rivereau les véhicules de la
police nationale qui sont en train de se
rapprocher petit à petit de l'Arc de
Triomphe voilà au bout de au bout des
Champs-Élysées pour l'instant on sent
qu'il y a de la tension dans l'air mais
la situation reste maîtrisée
rester à l'abri Timothée en espérant que
ça se passe bien évidemment et on
revient vous voir dans un instant on
continue nous parler de football qui
nous intéresse le principal le jeu et
Kylian Mbappé mérite-t-il la mérite la
note de 10 ce soir certains disent oui
certains disent non Vincent roseron nous
a dit que non après une défaite malgré
un triple en final de la coupe du monde
ça vaut 9 je donne la parole à ceux qui
sont d'accord avec lui Vincent du chêne
pareil au final il y a pas il y a pas de
victoire au bout et puis même s'il met
un triplé pendant 70 minutes il est il
est assez inexistant il est transparent
donc mettre un 10 à un joueur il faut
vraiment que le match soit parfait et
qu'à l'arrivée il y a une coupe du monde
là c'est pas le cas Cédric moi je mets
même que 8
alors là
quelle note pour moi j'en ai mis un
c'est quand même on a les meilleurs
joueurs au monde il a fait une très
belle finale il a été il nous a sauvé
les matchs c'est lui qui a sauvé qui a
sauvé les Argentins il a été grandios il
mérite pas moi Candice et effectivement
ou alors la 9,99 parce qu'il va pas
gagner effectivement les matchs et que
je pense que à un moment il gagnera à
nouveau une coupe du monde et qu'il peut
donner encore plus mais pour moi c'est
un disque encore une chance alors pour
essayer de statistique qui vient de
m'appeler le plus jeune a marqué lors de
deux finales différentes en Coupe du
monde à 23 ans et 360 jours mérite-t-il
9 ou 10 je j'ai écouté les arguments et
finalement je vais lui mettre 8,1 vous
êtes vraiment allez je je j'arrête avec
vous on a testé des champs euh s'il vous
plaît une autre statistique tiens
vendredi tu lui donnes
il lui donne 9 très bien alors je
voulais vous dire invisible en première
période elle m'a pas été recentrée
ensuite on a dû attendre la 70e minute
pour le voir armé une première frappe
ORCADE et une position de jeu la
suivante c'est le penalty et après
évidemment il lance mais ce qu'il met en
avant
innotable mais il a fait la différence
entre avec un triplé au final alors en
suspension voilà ce qu'ils disent cette
statistique c'est pas toujours facile à
dire surtout quand on a un bot de coupe
du monde et qu'on commence à fatiguer
quatre buts en finale 8 buts en phase
d'alumination en direct
10e 11e et 12e but à 23 ans voilà pour
les statistiques de Killian
comme ça
Argentine un peu statistique
et statistique c'est pas plus facile
pour moi
il y a toujours autant de
allez on a Didier Deschamps tiens euh
alors que cette déclaration s'enchaînent
on me dit dans l'oreillette on lit ce
que nous dit Raphaël Veran Varane on est
très déçu on a tout donné pendant une
heure on était pas dans le match oui on
l'a vu on est revenu on aurait pu gagner
aussi très cher des Français de ce
groupe on a tout donné en garde la tête
haute voilà ce que nous dit le vice
capitaine de l'équipe de France je crois
que c'est lui qui sera faite vannes on a
Didier Deschamps quelle note vous lui
donnez Cédric Callier allez-y vous avez
la parole je vous ai pardonne alors
j'hésite entre 9 et 10 et je vais lui
mettre neuf non c'est parce que alors
attendez vous avez critiqué Mbappé sur
ces 70 premières minutes vous critiquez
pas les le choix non pour la simple et
bonne raison que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec Cindy que sans doute
tactiquement il a été on a été pris par
l'Argentine au début et que ce Caloni a
remporté la bataille tactique mais
simplement qu'est-ce que Didier quelle
équipe type Didier Deschamps est-il pu
mettre d'autres que celle-ci par contre
le fait qu'il réagisse bien qui fasse
les bons emplacements dès la 40e il a
pas attendu il a tout de suite pris des
choses en main il a senti que son équipe
à tes pas dedans il a été proactif il a
relancé les mecs je pense qu'il les a
motivés à la mi-temps d'une manière
dingue c'était plus la même équipe en
seconde période donc je lui mets neuf
parce que je vois pas quel autre once de
départ si si pour contrer ça il décide
de mettre colosse un titulaire au final
oui vous m'avez convaincu je salue tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent sur Le
Figaro.fr parce que vous êtes nombreux
sur Youtube mais axen Charles Martel un
habitué Adeline évidemment qui débattent
entre eux vous continuez Didier
Deschamps Cindy vous lui donnez quelle
note c'est un génie
une finale de Coupe du monde en fait
qu'est-ce que c'est l'équipe de France
j'ai vu d'autres équipes en fait j'ai
l'habitude de regarder et honnêtement 10
même si effectivement il a été pris des
cours par l'escalonique a été également
très bon tactiquement je trouve que il a
eu la bonne réaction et c'était pas
facile j'ai juste trouvé que c'était un
petit peu précipité sur les sorties de
certains Georges par des Gilou peut-être
allez peut-être 9,8 j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de respect il est non non
il a bien réagi et je trouve que voilà
mais il a peut-être un peu moins bien
anticipé
Giroud c'est pas évident à émettre
sortir Dembélé pourquoi pas même si on
tire pas sur une ambulance mais Giroud
voilà on tire sur une ambulance en
finale de Coupe du monde mais c'est pas
posé question la 40e minute en plus je
pense que ça a donné à s'envoyer un
message
[Musique]
tous les deux en train d'embrasser la
Coupe du Monde on la revoit c'est beau
non et des champs aussi il y a quelque
chose d'important qui est aucun
sélectionne le monde je pense sur les pu
faire et des champs l'a fait c'est
vraiment faire en sorte que l'équipe de
France soit et une image parfaite au sud
du monde entier on s'est dit c'est
vraiment une belle équipe avec des
joueurs à la hauteur il a su vraiment
gérer des égaux il a quand même les
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui est à
l'intérieur et les meilleurs joueurs des
clubs qui est ben c'est moi qui était
qui devait être qui enfin bon qui était
blessé mais qui était quand même là et
pas là et donc voilà je pense que pour
l'avoir pu gérer tout ça d'une façon
excellente 10 je n'ai pas donné la note
sur Youtube de nos internautes celle
qu'ils ont donné à Kylian Mbappe 10 à
58%, 9 à 20% à 8 à 10% et 7 à 11%, je
j'arrête ce sondage et j'ouvre la
prochaine question
mais avant ça on continue de noter des
champs doit-il rester à la tête de
l'équipe de France avant ça Vincent
donnez-moi sa note sur ce match moi je
vais être moins généreux que mes
partenaires je vais lui mettre un huit
des champs parce que parce que oui il
change le petit d'accord avec vous il
change le cours du match mais au début
voilà quand on voit la difficulté du
match de Rafael Varane on se dit et ce
qu'il fallait le mettre titulaire quand
on voit Adrien rabiot comment il termine
complètement carbo cette rencontre et ce
qu'il fallait le métier
remplaçable le problème c'était de
mettre une charnière centrale connaîtée
ou pas mécano qui est très jeune qui
doit avoir peut-être aller au final
je dis peut-être 14-15 sélections à deux
regarde le match de Raphaël va regarde
la note qu'on lui a mis qu'est-ce que
vous auriez dit ah ils sont quand même
pas mis ils sont mis déjà ils sont pas
mis les câbles parce qu'il aurait pu
rassurer le 11 qui doit mettre qu'il a
pas le choix et après il a bien réagi
parce que ce Caloni a trouvé une parade
pour pour enfermer Griezmann et il a
magnifiquement réagi je trouve que voilà
il y avait cette image à Buenos Aires et
parallèle l'image sur les Champs-Élysées
parce qu'on l'a également avec il fait
chaud ça donne envie si Timothée peut
nous stabiliser l'image comme ça on peut
voir ce petit parallèle qui est superbe
entre entre ces deux pays ces deux
grandes capitales avec l'une d'entre
elles qui fête la victoire de ces
champions du monde ça va être assez
exceptionnel à mon avis et les
Champs-Élysées qui sont presque vides on
verra l'image dans un instant on
continue de parler de Didier Deschamps
ça bouge sur les Champs-Élysées mais
c'est vide
Vincent roseron Didier Deschamps la note
que vous lui donnez
je trouve que 8 c'est déjà sympa pour
lui j'entendais Cindy je vois qu'elle
voulait lui mettre 10 je suis désolé
mais si il a dit ce qu'elle dit il a
combien 14 voilà non non je suis il
s'est fait complètement voilà la
tactique de ce qu'elle a dit la
complètement pris de cours il a pas du
tout réussi son son début de match
ensuite il fait des bons changements
mais bravo de de se réveiller à la 40e
minute mais on n'oublie pas que si la
France a galéré pendant les 45 minutes
si elle a encaissé de but c'est aussi à
cause de cette tactique et donc du coup
je vois pas comment on peut lui mettre
beaucoup plus de 8 mois j'aurais été
même tenté de lui mettre 7
puisque de toute façon ils connaissent
quasiment de manière certaine l'once de
départ de l'équipe de France et que
voilà Didier Deschamps avec tous les
joueurs qui lui manquait ceux qui ont
été touchés par le par ce fameux virus
juste avant non je suis désolé je pense
qu'il met son onze alors certes il a
peut-être été trop conservateur et tout
mais il a tout de suite réagi dans cette
finale et je pense que la réaction c'est
important un problème d'attitude des
joueurs moi je trouve parce que au début
on a vu des joueurs qui manquait des
caractères qui mais c'est
pas exactement
donc je pense que je ne crois pas que
d'idées d'échange leur a dit allez si
laisser je crois pas franchement je
crois pas je salue tous ceux qui
continuent de nous rejoindre sur Youtube
Island Man et qui félicite les Argentins
je crois que ça y est la déception est
un peu passée bravo l'Argentine dommage
pour nos bleus nous dit Island man très
bon gardien l'Argentine dit
il paraît qu'il fait sur Colomiers en
toute fin de match c'est un but au moins
Sofia Miller oui bravo aux Argentins
bravo à eux allez on est en train de
jouer les prolongations de cette de ce
débrief la Coupe du Monde est finie la
prochaine aura lieu dans 3 ans et demi
maintenant avec quelle sélectionneur
c'est la dernière question qu'on se pose
ce soir Vincent roseron est-ce que
Deschamps va rester est-ce que on aura
dans les heures qui viennent une réponse
où on va devoir attendre encore un
moment
n'aurait jamais dû mettre Hernandez
titulaire ni Dembélé oui c'est vrai
on a plus derrière gauche donc on met
qu'à ma vinga tout de suite mais vu ce
qu'il avait montré contre la Tunisie ça
fait impossible regardez cette image
place de la Concorde alors il y a deux
obélisques vous avez vu l'Obélisque à
Buenos Aires
bien celui de la place de la Concorde et
c'est plutôt rigolo que les Argentins
soient réunis là-bas c'est un joli
symbole toujours dans l'obélisque quand
même c'était la Copa América on était
là-bas aussi vous étiez aussi oui
j'étais là vous retournez
sa veste comme ça vous êtes comme ça
c'était quand même River contre Boca qui
a été joué en Espagne et qu'on a fêté
là-bas euh on Argentine la liberté vous
ne faites qu'un seul geste vous
retournez votre veste
j'ai autre chose à vous dire non alors
attendez d'abord on parle de Didier
Deschamps pour finir
attention tout de suite merci
non dites-moi Didier Deschamps doit-il
rester allez on finit notre débat
rapidement je pense que oui et je suis
d'accord sur l'effet que la balle est
dans son camp d'ailleurs à un moment
il y avait quand même des informations
qui t'ont laissé sa date hein comme quoi
le numéro disait qu'elle a porté est
ouverte pour Zidane il voyait ça mais
c'est vrai qu'on a vu l'interview des
baptistes des prés pour le Noël des
Grecs où il indique que c'est vraiment
la balle est dans les camps de Didier
Deschamps et je pense que ça l'est
toujours cette finale elle a été bon
bien joué sur la fin on peut un être
fier et je pense qu'il a vraiment la
décision
Vincent moi je suis d'accord il faut
qu'il continue peut pas partir là-dessus
quoi la déception est énorme et puis
il a une revanche à prendre sur l'euro
aussi le rôle il l'a jamais gagné avec
l'équipe de France en tant que
sélectionneur donc pourquoi pas lui
donner un contrat jusqu'à jusqu'à
symbolique parce qu'on se souvient de
l'Euro 2000 c'est ça ou des champs et
sélectionnés et joueur capitaine et sur
la pelouse il y a cette discussion avec
Roger Le Maire qui lui dit ne t'arrête
pas continue on en est presque là est-ce
que Noël le Grey sur la pelouse ce qui
est manuel Macron est allé sur la
grenouille pour lui dire n'arrête pas
n'arrête pas Cédric je suis partagé je
suis partagé parce que alors moi je
pense qu'il devrait continuer parce que
j'adore ce qu'il fait et que je trouve
que en plus il a réussi un
renouvellement des cadres là
renouvellement de l'effectif j'ai
l'impression que son son discours passe
toujours auprès des joueurs et qui a
aucun souci à ce niveau là donc j'aurais
tendance à dire qu'il devrait continuer
après on sait qu'elle est l'ombre qui
est derrière ces Zidane donc c'est un
peu le
du roi quelque part si des champs
s'arrêtent et que c'est pour qu'on voit
Zidane à la tête des Bleus je suis aussi
ravi donc quoi qu'il va se passer je
suis ravi bonne chance à celui qui
succédera digérer
est-ce qu'on peut mettre ces images en
plein écran parce qu'elles sont
totalement hallucinantes et on continue
d'en parler ensemble dites-moi si vous
voulez régler vos comptes merci d'avoir
passé cette Coupe du monde avec nous
déjà
alors vous souvenez 1998
et bah figurez-vous qu'il y a l'argent
qui a sauvé l'honneur de l'Amérique du
Sud et dans les matchs qui a eu lieu
aujourd'hui c'est la gencive
non mais c'est vrai qu'entre les matchs
Europe Amérique du Sud on est il y a
match nul pour l'instant alors qu'est-ce
qui va se passer par la suite on verra
évidemment et moi je voulais vous dire
aussi que j'avais parlé
avec doublé de Mbappé et doubler de
Messi enfin j'avais pas vu le tripler
mais bon donc vous avez vous avez été
gros sur toute la Coupe du Monde merci
Cédric merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
Vincent roseron sur place allez à
dernier commentaire parce que vous étiez
sur place vous avez une chance immense
vous rentrez vite ah vous avez une
supportrice avec vous
racontez-nous parce que oui l'image pour
vous de cette Coupe du monde
l'image de cette Coupe du Monde c'est
c'est je sais pas ce que c'est l'image
cette coupe du monde mais en tout cas
c'était une coupe du monde magnifique on
peut le dire faut au niveau du jeu on a
eu des matchs incroyables et c'est cette
finale on est on est l'image vraiment
une coupe du monde vraiment vraiment
exceptionnelle
en tout cas sur le terrain ça a été ça a
été clairement une grande grande
réussite
et vous allez rentrer vous allez nous
raconter évidemment la vie au Qatar que
ça ça nous intéresse merci beaucoup
Vincent vous êtes avec une supportrice
non des Bleus une petite question
peut-être
ah Julie va je vais lui poser une petite
question parce que je crois qu'elle a
pas beaucoup de voix actuellement elle
me racontait qu'elle chantait
non je crois qu'elle viendra pas
malheureusement voilà
que vous connaissez peut-être c'est qui
qui travaille au Figaro euh en tant que
maquillage et donc voilà elle était elle
est passée elle est passée nous dire un
petit coucou quand même parfait on
l'embrasse Céline merci beaucoup merci
Vincent rentrez bien et j'entends
toujours j'ai l'impression les super
merci derrière vous tiens je finis avec
ça pour vous Cédric l'image de cette
Coupe du Monde ce que vous retiendrez là
moi c'était le par exemple en 2018 c'est
le but de Pavard je m'en serais toute ma
vie alors je sais pas si c'est un but
moi je trouve je vais je vais pas être
très original mais la photo qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure mais si qui embrasse la
Coupe du monde je trouve que c'est voilà
c'est une vie
deux choses j'ai les doigts les triplés
des vapés et Messi qui remporte la Coupe
du Monde enfin bon vous n'êtes pas très
original quoi finalement vous serez
finale
de je sais plus quel match j'étais
français
et en plus j'ai toujours été pour
l'Argentine en étant jeune au Venezuela
pour les sous-américains qui est enfin
Messi gagnent la Coupe du Monde c'est
c'était d'aller de toute façon s'en
souviendra vous Vincent Duchêne
les larmes de Neymar
parce que ouais on l'a senti
psychologiquement très atteint
d'ailleurs on va voir dans quel état il
va revenir au PSG et puis bah le bisou
de de mes 600 la Coupe du Monde quoi moi
je me souviendrai de je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu cette image avec le grand
sourire de Kylian Mbappe lorsqu'elle
vous avez vu je sais pas si vous avez vu
l'image et on va essayer de la retrouver
peut-être vous pouvez la chercher Demba
P euh filmer de loin qui
qui bondit et qui se rend compte à ce
moment-là que le raté de Kane change la
face et le destin de la Coupe du Monde
des Bleus quoi c'est assez hallucinant
et on voit toute la joie la libération
pour un penalty raté à la 75 minutes
t'as rien fait évidemment et à ce
moment-là on le sent on sent que son
destin est en marche la Mbappe Cédric il
y a une autre image moi qui me revient
là qui a rien à voir avec le football
mais c'est trop tard pour lancer ce type
de débat et c'est sans doute pas le
moment là mais les Allemands avec la
main sur la bouche et tout ça restera je
pense aussi une image qui qui marquera
quand même sur un autre point de vue la
supportrice iranienne qui brandit in
pancarte qui est sorti par la sécurité
du stade alors qu'elle août pour son
pays évidemment le football est toujours
politique quoi qu'on dit certains
sport n’échappera jamais à la politique
je donne le résultat de ma dernière
sondage il y ait des champs doit-il
rester à la tête de l'équipe de France
c'est un oui pour 65% de nos internautes
sur Youtube merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi merci d'avoir passé cette Coupe du
monde demande avec nous c'est fini en
apothéose malgré la défaite des Bleus je
crois qu'on a vécu une grande après-midi
tous ensemble merci Cédric merci
à tous le Service des Sports vous leur
passez un grand bonjour merci à Vincent
roseron sur place à Baptiste des prêts
évidemment Martin couturier le chef du
service des sports et puis tous ceux en
réagit il y a de Becker qui a fait un
travail énorme tout au long de la Coupe
du monde pour mettre en place ce plateau
pour nous équiper pour qu'on puisse
avoir les images partout à Buenos Aires
à la Concorde sur les Champs-Élysées
c'est grâce à lui je le remercie et puis
Julien Leclerc qui m'a aidé à tout
préparer aussi les ces petits cartons
ces petites photos ces petits sonores
des joueurs de l'équipe de France gusta
maurio qui s'occupait de la
programmation et puis la direction du
Figaro live avec avec Vincent roux et
Sylvain châtelain évidemment merci de
nous avoir suivis le foot c'est fini
pour un petit moment même si je pense
qu'on sera ensemble demain pour voir
s'il est bleu descendent les
Champs-Élysées on rattra évidemment pas
ça excellente soirée et vous restez sur
le figure life parce qu'il y a encore
plein d'informations autour la Coupe du
Monde salut